Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. For some time we did not speak. I left the window and stood behind his chair. So is it all up? I said. He answered without looking at me. Yes, it's all up. I sat down beside him with a feeling of numbness in my limbs and absently watched through the half-open door the backs of moving men. A secretary came in with foreign office boxes. He put them down and went out of the room. Henry sat at his writing table, leaning back with a pen in his hand. What was he thinking of? His sons? Would they all have to fight? I got up and lent my head
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的加更节目、无广告内容、抢先观看系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。有一段时间我们没有说话。我离开窗边，站在他的椅子后面。我说：“所以一切都结束了吗？”他没有看我，回答道：“是的，一切都结束了。”我坐在他身边，四肢感到一阵麻木，心不在焉地透过半开的门看着搬运工人的背影。一位秘书带着外交部的箱子走了进来。他放下箱子，走出了房间。亨利坐在写字台前，向后靠着，手里拿着一支笔。他在想什么？他的儿子们吗？他们都必须去打仗吗？我起身，把头靠在
against his. We could not speak for tears. So that was Margot Asquith, the wife of Herbert Henry Asquith, the Prime Minister of Britain, writing in her autobiography. She was remembering the evening of Tuesday, the 4th of August 1914, which was the night that Britain entered the Great War, the First World War, probably the greatest calamity in modern history, from which so much else flowed, so many of the great horrors that scarred the history of the 20th century. And for the Asquiths themselves, it was devastating. It destroyed the prime minister's premiership.
他的头上。我们泪流满面，无法言语。这就是英国首相赫伯特·亨利·阿斯奎斯的妻子玛戈·阿斯奎斯在自传中写下的内容。她回忆起1914年8月4日星期二的那个晚上，那是英国进入“大战”（第一次世界大战）的夜晚，这可能是现代史上最巨大的灾难，由此引发了后续的一切，以及许多在20世纪历史上留下伤痕的巨大恐怖。对于阿斯奎斯一家来说，这是毁灭性的。它摧毁了首相的任期。
But also, the premonitions were right. The Asquith sons did indeed join up, fight, and their elder son Raymond was killed exactly two years and two weeks later at the Battle of the Somme, the memory of which is still such a scar on the British historical memory. So Dominic, I mean, that's a brilliant and sobering reminder of everything that is at stake. Yeah, absolutely. Because it's not just the Asquiths, is it?
但预感也是正确的。阿斯奎斯的儿子们确实参军并参加了战斗，他们的长子雷蒙德在整整两年零两周后死于索姆河战役，这段记忆至今仍是英国历史记忆中一道深深的伤疤。多米尼克，我的意思是，这是一个精彩而发人深省的提醒，提醒我们一切都处于危险之中。是的，绝对是。因为不仅仅是阿斯奎斯一家，对吧？
I mean, it's millions of people in Britain. It's millions of people in all the various competent powers across Europe and in due course, you know, in continents beyond Europe as well. Yeah, absolutely. So as much as there have been very blackly comic moments in this series, of course, it's a series that ultimately at the end of it is a horrendous tragedy. And it's also a reminder, I think, that scene, the two of them crying, that these people, these decision makers, as we've said so many times, they do not go into this gladly and excitedly. They do not think it's a great adventure. They are literally crying as they make the crucial decisions. And so that's what makes me think we've referred a lot to Christopher Clarke's
我的意思是，这是英国的数百万人。这是欧洲各地所有相关大国的数百万人，当然，最终也包括欧洲以外的大陆。是的，绝对是。所以，尽管这个系列中有很多黑色幽默的时刻，但归根结底，这是一个可怕的悲剧。我认为这也是一个提醒，那一幕，他们两人哭泣的场景，提醒我们这些人，这些决策者，正如我们多次说过的，他们并不是兴高采烈地投入其中。他们并不认为这是一场伟大的冒险。他们在做出关键决定时，确实是在哭泣。这就是为什么我认为我们多次提到克里斯托弗·克拉克
brilliant and groundbreaking book on this process, The Sleepwalkers. I don't think they are sleepwalkers. No, I agree with you. I've always thought about that book, that it's an oddly chosen title. Yeah. Because many of them, their eyes are wide open
关于这一过程的精彩且开创性的著作《梦游者》。我不认为他们是梦游者。不，我同意你的看法。我一直觉得那本书的书名选得很奇怪。是的。因为他们中的许多人，眼睛是睁得大大的，
and they are tormented by the decisions they're making. They think they're the right decisions. They think they have no alternative. But I don't think they are like sleepers, stumbling down a hall, not knowing what's going on. I think they know only too well what is coming. I mean, that moment, would his sons have to fight? As you said, the premonition. And we'll see later in this final episode that that was shared not just by the high and mighty, but by people all across society who knew that something terrible was coming at the end of all this. And yet it certainly in Britain, it dawns on them so late, doesn't it?
而且他们被自己所做的决定折磨着。他们认为这是正确的决定。他们认为自己别无选择。但我不认为他们像梦游者一样，跌跌撞撞地走在走廊里，不知道发生了什么。我认为他们非常清楚即将发生什么。我的意思是，那一刻，他的儿子们必须去打仗吗？正如你所说的，那种预感。我们将在本季最后一集中看到，这种预感不仅被高层人士所共有，而且被社会各界人士所共有，他们都知道这一切的终点将会有可怕的事情发生。然而，在英国，他们意识到这一点确实太晚了，不是吗？
Yes, it does. Yeah, that's another thing that we'll discover today. So we ended last time, Tom, on the evening of Thursday, the 30th of July, the Austrians had begun firing on Belgrade. The stream of telegrams between Nicholas II and Wilhelm II has come to an end. They've basically fallen out with each other. The Kaiser is ranting and raving about shopkeepers and- Edward VII. Edward VII. The ghost of Edward VII.
是的，确实如此。是的，这是我们今天将要发现的另一件事。所以，汤姆，我们上次结束时是在7月30日星期四的晚上，奥地利人已经开始炮击贝尔格莱德。尼古拉二世和威廉二世之间的电报往来已经结束。他们基本上已经闹翻了。德皇在咆哮，谈论着店主和——爱德华七世。爱德华七世。爱德华七世的幽灵。
And the Tsar, the final moment, we entered in the telegraph office in St. Petersburg, the Tsar having ordered general mobilization and the order going out across the Russian empire so the question now I mean we can take this day by day because we're into the last three or four days of this whole story the first question is how will the Germans respond to the news of Russian mobilization the moment by the way that the Germans have been dreading and expecting and preparing for, not just for weeks, but for years. So overnight, they had a massive row, the Kaiser's commanders and his ministers, because their whole plan was predicated on speed, but now they've realised they're in danger of falling behind the Russians. So midday, they get a telegram from St Petersburg confirming the
而在圣彼得堡的电报局，沙皇下达了总动员令，命令传遍了整个俄罗斯帝国，所以现在的问题是，我的意思是我们可以逐日分析，因为我们已经进入了整个故事的最后三四天，第一个问题是德国人将如何回应俄国动员的消息，顺便说一句，这是德国人一直担心、期待并为此准备的时刻，不仅是几周，而是几年。所以一夜之间，德皇的指挥官和大臣们发生了激烈的争吵，因为他们的整个计划都是基于速度，但现在他们意识到自己有落后于俄国人的危险。所以中午，他们收到了一份来自圣彼得堡的电报，证实了
Russians have moved from partial mobilisation to general mobilization. In other words, they're getting all of their men into line and moving to the borders preparing for war. And they decide that they will move to this thing that they talked about, we talked about last time, that the Kaiser will declare a state of imminent danger of war. So that will mean martial law in Germany, the censorship of the press, the railways taken over by the military, the frontiers taken over by the military, and so on and so forth. I mean, Wilhelm is a man who loves ritual and ceremony, and he loves playing the part of a king and emperor. And so that afternoon, they meet in the royal palace in Berlin in their star chamber. And Wilhelm, he's sort of ranting a bit, as he often does, under stress and saying, this is all the Russians, what absolute dogs they are, terrible people. His staff give him the order to sign, and he insists. He says, I must stand up to sign it. So he stands up and he signs this
俄国人已经从部分动员转为总动员。换句话说，他们正在集结所有兵力并向边境移动，准备战争。他们决定采取我们上次谈到的那种行动，即德皇将宣布进入“战争危险状态”。这意味着德国将实行戒严，新闻审查，铁路被军方接管，边境被军方接管，等等。我的意思是，威廉是一个热爱仪式和庆典的人，他喜欢扮演国王和皇帝的角色。所以那天下午，他们在柏林的皇宫里召开了秘密会议。威廉在压力下经常咆哮，他说，这都是俄国人的错，他们真是彻头彻尾的狗，可怕的人。他的参谋人员让他签字，他坚持要站着签。所以他站起来，签下了
thing. And Erich von Falkenhayn, his Prussian war minister, says his bearing and language were worthy of a German emperor, worthy of a Prussian king. You know, finally, the Kaiser has risen to the moment and not disgraced himself by behaving like Mr. Toad. And the same day, they send two ultimatums, one to Russia and one to France. To Russia, they say, you must halt your military preparations, which are clearly aimed at us. If you don't, we will make preparations ourselves. And to France, they say, you have basically until tomorrow afternoon to declare your neutrality.
这份文件。埃里希·冯·法尔肯海恩，他的普鲁士战争大臣说，他的举止和语言配得上德国皇帝，配得上普鲁士国王。你知道，德皇终于挺身而出，没有像“蛤蟆先生”那样表现得丢人现眼。同一天，他们发出了两份最后通牒，一份给俄国，一份给法国。对俄国，他们说，你们必须停止针对我们的军事准备。如果不停止，我们将采取我们自己的准备。对法国，他们说，你们基本上只有到明天下午的时间来宣布中立。
Otherwise, the gloves are off. And do they send a message to Britain? Well, of course, in Britain, people have been under a bit of a fog. So actually, this same day, Friday the 31st, is the day I would say that most people in Britain finally realise this is something serious. You know how it is. We've talked about this so many times, especially when we're talking about modern history. At any given moment, most people have no idea what's going on because they're not following the news. They've got better things to think about. Well, this is the Baldrick joke in Blackadder Goes Forth, isn't it? Baldrick's you know he's the the batman yeah the dim-witted the dim-witted
否则，就不客气了。他们给英国发消息了吗？嗯，当然，在英国，人们一直处于一种迷雾之中。所以实际上，这一天，即8月31日星期五，我认为是英国大多数人终于意识到这是一件严重事情的日子。你知道是怎么回事。我们谈论过很多次了，特别是在谈论现代历史时。在任何特定时刻，大多数人根本不知道发生了什么，因为他们没有关注新闻。他们有更重要的事情要考虑。嗯，这就是《黑爵士》中鲍德里克笑话的梗，对吧？鲍德里克，你知道他是那个侍从，是的，那个愚笨的
batman and and says i heard that it started when a bloke called archie duke shot an ostrich because he was hungry yeah exactly so this is the first time that you've got basically the newspapers saying oh my god there's going to be a war and the sort of the popular press as it were and not only that the city of london is in chaos people are rushing to get money the bank of england suspended payments in gold and they've actually for the first time in history had to close the stock exchange to try to prevent a massive crash as people panic so absolutely people in britain now are realizing something is up and they get a message from the germans so sorry to answer your question Tom is there an
侍从，他说：“我听说这事儿始于一个叫‘阿奇公爵’（Archduke）的家伙因为饿了射杀了一只鸵鸟。”是的，完全正确。所以这是报纸基本上第一次说“天哪，要打仗了”，也就是所谓的通俗报刊。不仅如此，伦敦金融城一片混乱，人们争先恐后地取钱，英格兰银行暂停了黄金支付，他们历史上第一次不得不关闭证券交易所，试图防止人们恐慌导致的股市崩盘。所以绝对地，英国人现在意识到出事了，他们收到了德国人的消息。所以，汤姆，回答你的问题，有没有给英国的
ultimatum to Britain not an ultimatum there is a message basically begging the British to stay out so the German Chancellor Therbald Bettman-Holweg sends a message to the British Foreign Secretary Sir Edward Grey and he says please if we promise that we won't annex any French territory if there's a war will you stay out and Grey Gray says, no, I cannot give you that guarantee. Such a bargain would be a disgrace from which the good name of this country could never recover. Okay. Is that accurate? I mean, is his principle British honour requires, you know, it would be an affront to the dignity of the British empire or are there more Machiavellian reasons? Are there reasons to do with British self-interest that is about more than just matters of principle? I mean, what is at stake there? because we had said for so long, of course, they have nothing in writing, that famous line that Cedric Gray used earlier in the series,
最后通牒？不是最后通牒，而是一条基本上恳求英国保持中立的消息。所以德国首相特奥巴尔德·冯·贝特曼-霍尔维格给英国外交大臣爱德华·格雷爵士发了一条消息，他说：“拜托，如果我们承诺如果发生战争我们不会吞并任何法国领土，你们会保持中立吗？”格雷说：“不，我不能给你那个保证。这样的交易将是一种耻辱，这个国家的好名声将永远无法恢复。”好的。这准确吗？我的意思是，他的原则是“英国荣誉要求”，你知道，这会是对大英帝国尊严的侮辱，还是有更马基雅维利式的理由？是否有关于英国自身利益的理由，而不仅仅是原则问题？我的意思是，那里有什么利害关系？因为我们说了很久，当然，他们没有任何书面保证，就是塞德里克·格雷在系列节目早期用的那句名言，
but that if we walk away from France now, our word will mean nothing in international affairs. But not only that, that it would be a strategic defeat for Britain, because France would fall, that Germany will control the Channel ports and so on. Because, I mean, just to, I can't remember if we've mentioned this, we've done so many episodes on this, but the French fleet is not in the channel because the British have guaranteed that they will keep an enemy fleet out of the channel. So if Britain stays neutral, then there's nothing to stop the German fleet from descending on Northern France. Correct. Exactly right. And Grey feels a huge sense of obligation. Now, when we first introduced Gray in this story, we said, he has not made that public.
但如果我们现在离开法国，我们在国际事务中的话语权将毫无意义。不仅如此，这对英国来说将是一场战略失败，因为法国会沦陷，德国将控制海峡港口等等。因为，我的意思是，我记不清我们是否提到过这一点，我们在这个问题上做了很多集节目，但法国舰队不在海峡，因为英国保证他们会把敌方舰队挡在海峡之外。所以如果英国保持中立，那么就没有什么能阻止德国舰队降临法国北部了。正确。完全正确。格雷感到一种巨大的义务感。现在，当我们第一次在故事中介绍格雷时，我们说，他并没有公开这一点。
So that is news to a lot of his liberal colleagues and, of course, to a lot of the general public. They say, what obligation do we have to France? And the fact that Gray has in private assured the French ambassador, oh, we'll always stand by you. But, I mean, how tense for the French ambassador. Right. Because the French ambassador, as we will see,
所以这对他的许多自由党同事，当然还有许多公众来说都是新闻。他们说，我们对法国有什么义务？事实上，格雷私下里向法国大使保证，“哦，我们永远会支持你们。”但是，这对法国大使来说是多么紧张啊。对。因为法国大使，正如我们将要看到的，
is extremely worried that actually Grey isn't going to deliver on this promise. Prophidious Albion. So Prophidious Albion. Right. That image of Prophidious Albion, by the way. You see, here's the interesting thing. Everybody in Britain thinks our word is our bond, an Englishman, a cricketer, and a gentleman.
非常担心格雷实际上不会兑现这个承诺。“背信弃义的阿尔比恩”（Perfidious Albion）。所以“背信弃义的阿尔比恩”。对。顺便说一句，那个“背信弃义的阿尔比恩”的形象。你看，有趣的是。英国的每个人都认为“我们的话就是我们的契约”，一个英国人，一个板球运动员，一个绅士。
Everybody abroad thinks you can never count on the British. They will always desert you and stab you in the back. Now, of course, there are some people associated with this podcast, Tom, who would suggest that this is precisely what Britain should have done. However, we will discuss that in due course. Now, the cabinet meets later that day. By and large, Gray is obviously moving much more towards intervention now, but most of his colleagues are still, no, no, it would be much better to stay out.
国外的每个人都认为你永远不能指望英国人。他们总会抛弃你，在背后捅你一刀。现在，当然，这个播客中有些人，汤姆，会建议这正是英国应该做的。然而，我们将在适当的时候讨论这个问题。现在，内阁当天晚些时候开会。总的来说，格雷显然现在正朝着干预的方向迈进，但他的大多数同事仍然认为，不，不，保持中立会好得多。
Churchill, the young Churchill, is very aggressive. But as Asquith writes to his would-be girlfriend, the girlfriend of his dreams anyway, Venetia Stanley. His daughter's friend. Yeah, 84 years his junior or whatever it is. And he says to her, everybody longs to stand aside. So the cabinet meeting breaks up and they have not decided to join the war in support of France. They all agree at an extraordinary concession from them in circumstances of Edwardian England
丘吉尔，年轻的丘吉尔，非常有侵略性。但正如阿斯奎斯写给他未来的女朋友，也就是他梦中的女朋友维尼西亚·斯坦利。他女儿的朋友。是的，比他小84岁还是什么的。他对她说：“每个人都渴望置身事外。”所以内阁会议解散了，他们还没有决定加入战争以支持法国。他们都同意——在爱德华时代的英国，这对于他们来说是一个非凡的让步——
that they won't go to the country, to their country estates. So Edward can't go fishing? He cannot go fishing. A bad blow for us all. But actually, Tom, an A bad blow for us all. But actually, Tom, an even bigger blow for Asquith. Asquith has been planning that he will go to a country house for a country house house party. Margot will come too, of course, but Venetia will be there.
他们不会去乡下，去他们的乡村庄园。所以爱德华不能去钓鱼了？他不能去钓鱼。这对我们所有人来说都是一个沉重的打击。但实际上，汤姆，这对阿斯奎斯来说是一个更大的打击。阿斯奎斯一直计划去一个乡村别墅参加乡村别墅派对。玛戈当然也会去，但维尼西亚也会在那里。
And he's very excited about it. And now he can't. He's taking a bullet for the team there then. He writes to Venetia and he says, I'm going to have to miss this party because of this bloody awful business in the balkans i can honestly say i've never had a more bitter disappointment he he's so disappointed he says he cannot sleep not because he's worried about the war he's got it he's the real victim in all this tom yeah he is so however the great
他对此非常兴奋。现在他去不了了。他当时是在为团队挡子弹。他写信给维尼西亚说：“因为巴尔干半岛这件该死的糟糕事情，我不得不错过这个派对，我可以诚实地说，我从未有过比这更痛苦的失望。”他太失望了，他说他睡不着觉，不是因为他担心战争，他已经得到了，他是这一切中真正的受害者，汤姆。是的，他是。然而，1910年代自由党政治家的伟大之处在于，
thing about um liberal politicians of the 1910s was they had tremendous composure and poise. So he's able to put that disappointment behind him because Sir Edward Grey has gone to his club to have dinner and to play billiards. I so admire that. And then... I genuinely admire that.
他们有极大的镇定和从容。所以他能够把那种失望抛在脑后，因为爱德华·格雷爵士已经去他的俱乐部吃晚饭并打台球了。我非常钦佩这一点。然后……我真心钦佩这一点。
He goes to Number 10 to play bridge with the Asquiths. Yeah. Margot said in her journal or whatever it was, Sir Edward came in and played bridge. He was very grave and silent, but he was in quite good form. Grey has in some ways an undeveloped schoolboy side to him, but he's quite as un-upsetable as Henry is. So that's fine.
他去唐宁街10号和阿斯奎斯一家打桥牌。是的。玛戈在她的日记还是什么东西里说，爱德华爵士进来打了桥牌。他非常严肃和沉默，但他的状态相当不错。格雷在某些方面有一种未成熟的学童气质，但他和亨利一样，是那种不容易被打乱的人。所以没关系。
They're playing their cards and stuff. And after this, Grey says, well, maybe we should make one last diplomatic effort. So he and Asquith, I'm sure port has been taken or whatever, they say, let's write a telegram. Let's get George V in on the telegram action. So a telegram to send to the Tsar to say, would you consider halting your mobilisation and giving us, the British, more time to try and mediate? So it's half past one now. Drink has definitely been taken at this point. But the king would definitely, by this point, have gone to bed, wouldn't he?
他们正在打牌什么的。之后，格雷说：“好吧，也许我们应该做最后一次外交努力。”所以他和阿斯奎斯，我敢肯定他们喝了波特酒什么的，他们说：“让我们写一封电报。让我们让乔治五世参与到电报行动中来。”所以给沙皇发一封电报，说：“你是否会考虑停止动员，给我们，英国人，更多的时间来尝试调解？”现在已经一点半了。此时肯定已经喝了酒。但国王到这个时候肯定已经上床睡觉了，不是吗？
He has gone to bed. He'd have had an evening studying stamps, stamp collecting magazines, and then tucked up with his cocoa. Exactly. Asquith and Grey's private secretary, they have to go out and flag down a taxi. It's quite difficult to do.
他已经上床睡觉了。他会花一个晚上研究邮票，收集邮票杂志，然后喝着可可上床。完全正确。阿斯奎斯和格雷的私人秘书，他们不得不出去拦一辆出租车。这很难做到。
There aren't many. It takes them ages to even find a taxi. They get into the taxi. Off they go to Buckingham Palace. They basically have to get the king out of bed. Asquith says himself, he was wearing a brown dressing gown over his knight shirt and had showed copious signs of having been wakened from his beauty sleep. So the king is standing there like bleary-eyed in his dressing gown.
没几辆。他们花了很长时间才找到一辆出租车。他们上了出租车。他们前往白金汉宫。他们基本上不得不把国王从床上叫醒。阿斯奎斯自己说，他穿着一件棕色的睡袍套在睡衣外面，表现出明显的刚从美梦中被唤醒的迹象。所以国王站在那里，睡眼惺忪地穿着睡袍。
Asquith reads him the message. The king says, fine, but he insists on one change. He wants to actually make it more personal so he puts in the words my dear Nicky at the beginning and then he insists
阿斯奎斯向他宣读了信息。国王说，好吧，但他坚持要改动一个地方。他想让它更个性化，所以他在开头加上了“我亲爱的尼基”（my dear Nicky），然后他坚持
on signing it Georgie which is very sweet but actually does no good at all it's a total and utter waste of time this telegram so finally the king is allowed to go back to bed they all go to bed
签上“乔吉”（Georgie），这很可爱，但实际上一点用都没有，这封电报完全是浪费时间。所以最后国王被允许回去睡觉，他们也都去睡觉了。
Saturday the 1st of August really I think now this is just an exercise in kind of blaming each other while the clock ticks down. And this involves the German ambassador, doesn't it? In St. Petersburg. Yes. Delivering an ultimatum. Yes. And you've talked regularly about how ambassadors in this period all have the wrong name.
8月1日星期六，我真的认为现在这只是一种互相指责的练习，同时时钟在滴答作响。这涉及德国大使，不是吗？在圣彼得堡。是的。递交最后通牒。是的。你经常谈到这个时期的大使名字都搞错了。
Yeah. So the German ambassador has a French name. Yeah. Count Portales. Yeah. Portales, I think it is. He's of Swiss background, I believe, Tom. Very confusing. Yeah, everybody, Benkendorf, Lichnowsky, they're all the ambassador from the wrong country to the wrong place.
是的。所以德国大使有一个法国名字。是的。波塔莱斯伯爵（Count Portales）。是的。我想是波塔莱斯。汤姆，我相信他是瑞士背景。非常令人困惑。是的，每个人，本肯多夫、利希诺夫斯基，他们都是从错误的国家派往错误地方的大使。
I think that's fair to say. And the Austrians are the worst for this. Anyway, so the French cabinet is meeting that morning and deciding on mobilisation. Still, in Britain, the sense is we will stay out. There's only really one newspaper that has been really keen on getting involved, and that's always been the Times. Your paper. Always a very anti-German paper. Most of the papers are still at this point. Don't forget, Britain is only three days away from joining the
我认为这样说是公平的。奥地利人在这方面是最糟糕的。总之，法国内阁那天早上开会决定动员。在英国，人们的感觉仍然是我们会置身事外。只有一份报纸一直非常热衷于参与，那就是《泰晤士报》。你的报纸。一直是一份非常反德的报纸。大多数报纸此时仍然如此。别忘了，英国距离加入战争只有三天了。
war. But still, the Daily Chronicle, we must not fight the Germans. It says, the great people whose civilization is in many ways the most akin in Europe to our own. The idea of a ruinous conflict between us seems more unqualifiedly distasteful now than it has perhaps for a generation. So that's again picking up on the idea that actually Anglo-German relations have been improving. Exactly. It's so interesting and so counterintuitive, given everything that we believe about the road to the First World War. The cabinet meets again. Still, they can't decide.
但《每日纪事报》仍然说：“我们绝不能与德国人作战。”它说：“这个伟大的民族，其文明在许多方面是欧洲与我们最相似的。在我们之间发生毁灭性冲突的想法，现在比一代人以来任何时候都更令人反感。”所以这又回到了 Anglo-German 关系实际上一直在改善的想法。完全正确。这非常有趣，而且非常违反直觉，考虑到我们关于第一次世界大战之路所相信的一切。内阁再次开会。他们仍然无法决定。
And now they're very conscious that if the cabinet splits, actually, what happens to Britain? What happens is the government falls. And after this long period of intense partisanship about Ireland, about the House of Lords, about taxes, all of these things. The liberals are booted out and the Tories come in, or the Unionists, as they were called then. And say, what is the Tory position on this? Let's get stuck in. We love a war. That's their position. They have met privately the Tory leaders,
现在他们非常清楚，如果内阁分裂，实际上，英国会发生什么？政府会倒台。在经历了关于爱尔兰、上议院、税收等问题的长期激烈党派斗争之后。自由党被踢出局，保守党（或者当时被称为统一党）上台。他们说，保守党对此的立场是什么？让我们加入吧。我们喜欢战争。这就是他们的立场。保守党领袖们私下会面了，
Bonalor, Balfour, F.E. Smith, and they have decided that they are all for the war. They want to stand by France and they want to get stuck in. I mean, it's an interesting question about why the Tories. I have to confess, I'm not sufficiently well-read on Tory politics in the early 1910s to know the answer about why they're so keen. I think they regard it as the patriotic thing to do and they like the idea of flexing Britain's muscles and not staying out. And maybe also it's just a way of getting the liberals out. Of course, it's a way of getting the liberals out. Exactly. So the cabinet meeting this time again breaks up. No decision. Now, interestingly, Churchill wanted to mobilize the fleet.
博纳·劳、贝尔福、F.E. 史密斯，他们决定他们都支持战争。他们想支持法国，想加入战斗。我的意思是，关于为什么保守党会这样，这是一个有趣的问题。我必须承认，我对1910年代初的保守党政治了解不够，不知道他们为什么如此热衷。我认为他们认为这是爱国行为，他们喜欢展示英国肌肉而不是置身事外的想法。也许这也是让自由党下台的一种方式。当然，这是让自由党下台的一种方式。完全正确。所以这次内阁会议再次解散。没有决定。现在，有趣的是，丘吉尔想动员舰队。
Everybody said, no, terrible idea. Very provocative. And at the end, they all go out. And on this way out, Churchill says to Asquith, how about it? Let me mobilize the fleet. And Churchill said, he looked at me with a hard stare and gave a sort of grunt. I did not require anything else. So Churchill actually is getting the fleet to its kind of war stations in readiness. The French, however, are horrified that the British have still not come to a decision. So remember Paul Cambon, who refuses to speak any English. Well, can't speak English, apparently. And doesn't agree with the idea of people and French people going to English schools.
每个人都说，不，太可怕了。非常挑衅。最后，他们都出去了。在出去的路上，丘吉尔对阿斯奎斯说：“怎么样？让我动员舰队吧。”丘吉尔说，他盯着我看了很久，发出了一声咕哝。我不需要任何其他东西。所以丘吉尔实际上正在让舰队进入战备状态。然而，法国人对英国仍然没有做出决定感到震惊。所以记住保罗·康邦（Paul Cambon），他拒绝说任何英语。嗯，显然不会说英语。而且不同意人们和法国人去英国学校的想法。
So bad news for our producer, Theo. Cambon meets Gray, and he is virtually in tears. He's white, and he says to him, this point that you made, Tom, you promised us. We sent away our fleet because we thought your fleet would protect us. Will you not help us? Yeah. And doesn't he famously say, I'm waiting to see if the word honor must be struck out of the English dictionary? That's right. And Gray basically says, we still haven't made up our minds, sorry.
这对我们的制片人西奥来说是个坏消息。康邦会见格雷，他几乎泪流满面。他脸色苍白，对他说：“汤姆，你提到的这一点，你答应过我们。我们遣散了我们的舰队，因为我们认为你们的舰队会保护我们。你们不帮我们吗？”是的。他不是有名地说了那句吗：“我正在等待看看‘荣誉’这个词是否必须从英语词典中删除？”没错。格雷基本上说：“抱歉，我们还没拿定主意。”
Cambon says to his aides, ils vont nous lâcher. They're going to let us down. Those buggers, they are going to ditch us. He really believes it. And in the Foreign Office, there are some people who are actually threatening to resign. Air Crow. And this is over a point of principle. Yeah, because we promised the French. That's their claim. We promised the French, even though we had nothing in writing. This is, I suppose you would say, you gave the example in a previous episode of the historian Neil Ferguson, who thinks Gray was negligent here. And you could say, this is the problem when you run informal secret foreign policy, that actually you've made promises and maybe you don't have the capacity to keep them. You have issued checks. You've issued checks.
康邦对他的助手说：“ils vont nous lâcher”（他们要抛弃我们了）。那些混蛋，他们要抛弃我们了。他真的相信这一点。在外交部，有些人甚至威胁要辞职。艾尔·克劳（Air Crow）。这是出于原则问题。是的，因为我们答应了法国人。这是他们的主张。我们答应了法国人，尽管我们没有任何书面保证。我想你会说，你在之前的一集中举了历史学家尼尔·弗格森的例子，他认为格雷在这里玩忽职守。你可以说，这就是当你进行非正式的秘密外交政策时出现的问题，实际上你做出了承诺，也许你没有能力兑现。你开出了支票。你开出了支票。
Without requisite capital behind them. Exactly that. Now, if that is an emotional scene, there are two more absolutely extraordinary emotional scenes to come today on this Saturday, the 1st of August. The first is in St. Petersburg. At 7pm exactly, the ambassador that you mentioned, Tom, Count Portales, is admitted to the Russian foreign ministry and Sergei Sazonov, the foreign minister, is waiting to receive him. Portales says to him three times, will you stop your military measures? And Sazanov says, no, no, niet, or probably non. They're probably speaking French, actually. He says, non, non, non. And Portales is very moved. He's kind of shaking. He's breathing heavily.
没有足够的资本支持。完全正确。现在，如果那是一个感人的场景，今天这个8月1日星期六还有两个绝对非凡的感人场景。第一个是在圣彼得堡。下午7点整，汤姆，你提到的那位大使，波塔莱斯伯爵，被准许进入俄国外交部，外交部长谢尔盖·萨佐诺夫正在等他。波塔莱斯对他说了三次：“你会停止你的军事措施吗？”萨佐诺夫说：“不，不，niet，或者可能是non。”他们实际上可能在说法语。他说：“non, non, non。”波塔莱斯非常感动。他有点颤抖。他呼吸沉重。
And he says, in that case, Monsieur le Ministre, I am commanded to give you this note. And the note is the declaration of war. And at that point, Portales totally loses it, breaks down in tears, puts his hand to his head and says, I never would have believed that I would leave St. Petersburg under circumstances like this. I can't believe it. And he's crying. And incredibly, Sazonov starts crying as well and says to him in French, believe me, monsieur, one day we will meet again. And they embraced each other before Portales went out of the room. Quite a contrast to how Germany will declare war on Russia later in the century.
他说：“如果是这样，部长先生，我奉命给你这份照会。”这份照会就是宣战书。在那一刻，波塔莱斯彻底崩溃了，泪流满面，双手抱头说：“我绝不会相信我会在这样的情况下离开圣彼得堡。我不敢相信。”他在哭。令人难以置信的是，萨佐诺夫也开始哭泣，并用法语对他说：“相信我，先生，总有一天我们会再见面的。”在波塔莱斯走出房间之前，他们拥抱了彼此。这与后来世纪德国如何向俄国宣战形成了鲜明对比。
Right. But again, a reminder that these people often had quite strong personal relationships. They belong to a kind of international caste, I suppose, don't they? Of aristocratic diplomats. And they've often rattled their sabres, but they had never really imagined that they would ever get to this point. Now, even if that's emotional, even more emotional and frankly bizarre is the scene in Berlin. Wilhelm, who's obviously been kept out of the capital as much as possible to avoid creating a scene, is driven in from Potsdam.
对。但再次提醒我们，这些人通常有相当强烈的个人关系。我想他们属于一种国际种姓，不是吗？贵族外交官。他们经常挥舞军刀，但他们从未真正想象过他们会走到这一步。现在，即使那很感人，更感人且坦率地说更离奇的是柏林的场景。威廉，显然为了避免制造混乱而尽可能被挡在首都之外，从波茨坦开车进来。
He goes down the main, the Great Avenue, Unter den Linden in Berlin, and he's dressed up. He loves, we know the Kaiser loves to dress up. It's pretty clear from all the sources you've been citing that he didn't actually want to go to war. No. He shrunk from it. But now the bullet has been bitten. I mean, this is kind of what he's made for, isn't it? Yeah.
他沿着主干道，柏林的菩提树下大街走，他盛装打扮。他喜欢，我们知道德皇喜欢打扮。从你引用的所有资料来看，很明显他实际上并不想去打仗。不。他对此退缩了。但现在箭在弦上。我的意思是，这正是他为之而生的，不是吗？是的。
A grand histrionic scene that involves dressing up and posing and strutting. Exactly. He's made for it. I mean, he's frightened of it, I think, but at the same time, there's part of him that secretly probably quite enjoys it. He's got his uniform on the cavalryman of guard, massive crowds, of course, waving flags and cheering him, which is what he wants. He goes to his palace at five o'clock. The War Minister Falkenhayn, the Chancellor Bethlehem Holbeck come in with the mobilisation order. And he signs it, Tom, at a table hewn from the wood of HMS Victory, of Nelson's flagship.
一个宏大的、戏剧性的场景，涉及打扮、摆姿势和昂首阔步。完全正确。他是为此而生的。我的意思是，他对此感到害怕，但与此同时，他内心深处可能也相当享受。他穿着禁卫军骑兵的制服，当然，成群结队的群众挥舞着旗帜为他欢呼，这正是他想要的。他五点钟去了他的宫殿。战争大臣法尔肯海恩、首相贝特曼-霍尔维格带着动员令进来了。他签了字，汤姆，在一张用纳尔逊旗舰“胜利号”（HMS Victory）的木头制成的桌子上。
And how has that come to pass? So this is a gift. It's a gift from his kith and kin in Britain. The irony. That was given as a gift to the Kaiser. Yeah, because HMS Victory, although it stands to this day and is a brilliant place to go and visit, it's constantly being renovated and repaired. So in the course of that, they've taken some of the timber and used it to help make a table.
这是怎么回事？所以这是一个礼物。这是他英国亲戚送的礼物。讽刺的是。那是送给德皇的礼物。是的，因为“胜利号”，虽然它至今屹立不倒，是一个参观的好地方，但它一直在翻新和修理。所以在那个过程中，他们取了一些木材，用来制作桌子。
So is there a kind of resonant symbolism in that? Well, if you're going to smite the French, what better table to use, right? Yeah. But is he also identifying himself with the Anglo-Saxons? No, I don't think so. We might like to think that, Tom, because we're a patriotic podcast. Well, I'm just wondering. I mean, is he thinking, well, the British are not going to join with the French?
所以这其中有一种共鸣的象征意义吗？嗯，如果你要打击法国人，还有什么比这更好的桌子呢，对吧？是的。但他是否也在认同盎格鲁-撒克逊人？不，我不这么认为。汤姆，我们可能想那样认为，因为我们是一个爱国播客。嗯，我只是在想。我的意思是，他是在想，嗯，英国人不会和法国人一起加入吗？
Ah, well, we will come to this. Blucher and Wellington, the old alliance. Right. I don't know. I mean, or whether it's just it's a convenient table that happens to be at hand. Could there be a better table than a table made from the timbers of Hitchman's Victory? Well, obviously, I don't think so. But I think it's probably a convenient table.
啊，好吧，我们会谈到这一点。布吕歇尔和威灵顿，旧联盟。对。我不知道。或者这只是一个手边方便的桌子。还有比用“胜利号”木材制成的桌子更好的桌子吗？嗯，显然，我不这么认为。但我认为这可能是一张方便的桌子。
I don't think, to be honest, I think they've got other things on their mind than the provenance of tables. Anyway, he signs this thing. Falkenhayn says, may God bless your majesty in your arms. May God protect our beloved fatherland. And they've all got tears in their eyes. They're all shaking hands. The Kaiser goes onto the balcony of their palace and there's a huge crowd outside
老实说，我不认为他们除了桌子的来源之外还有别的心思。总之，他签了这份文件。法尔肯海恩说：“愿上帝保佑陛下和你们的军队。愿上帝保佑我们敬爱的祖国。”他们眼里都含着泪水。他们都在握手。德皇走到宫殿的阳台上，外面有巨大的人群
and they sing the Lutheran hymn, Now thank we all our God. And that had been a huge patriotic anthem in Prussia because Frederick the Great's soldiers had sung it on the battlefield. So it's a very sort of stirring scene if you're German. And the Kaiser then gives this very famous speech where he says, Ich kenne keine Parteien mehr, ich kenne nur Deutsche.
他们唱着路德教的赞美诗《现在我们感谢上帝》（Now thank we all our God）。这在普鲁士一直是一首巨大的爱国赞歌，因为腓特烈大帝的士兵曾在战场上唱过它。所以如果你是德国人，这是一个非常令人激动的场景。德皇随后发表了那篇非常著名的演讲，他说：“Ich kenne keine Parteien mehr, ich kenne nur Deutsche.”
I no longer see political parties, I see only Germans. All that matters now is that we stand together like brothers and God will help the German sword to victory. This is the part for which he's been rehearsing all his life. It is. And actually, do you know who he reminds me of at this point? Somebody else who rehearsed for this role all his life, Churchill. Churchill.
“我不再看到政党，我只看到德国人。”现在唯一重要的是我们像兄弟一样站在一起，上帝会帮助德国之剑取得胜利。这是他一生都在排练的角色。是的。而且，你知道他此时让我想起了谁吗？另一个一生都在为这个角色排练的人，丘吉尔。丘吉尔。
Because Churchill gave a version of that speech in 1940 when he said, we may have differed and quarrelled in the past, but now one bond unites us all to wage war until victory is won. And that idea, all those petty divisions are gone. We are Germans stroke Britons. And I suppose that to the degree that there is feeling of excitement and happiness, that's part of what underlies it, isn't it? I mean, that passage with which we began that series in Vienna, that everybody is joined together in a common sense of purpose. Yes. And I think, Tom, it's actually, you know, all those crowds,
因为丘吉尔在1940年发表了那个演讲的版本，他说：“我们过去可能存在分歧和争吵，但现在一个纽带将我们所有人团结在一起，进行战争直到胜利。”那种想法，所有那些琐碎的分歧都消失了。我们是德国人/英国人。我想，在某种程度上，如果有一种兴奋和快乐的感觉，这就是其基础的一部分，不是吗？我的意思是，我们在维也纳那个系列开始时的那段话，每个人都为了一个共同的目标而团结在一起。是的。而且我认为，汤姆，实际上，你知道，所有那些人群，
when people talk about the outbreak of the First World War, people were delighted. They thought they'd be home by Christmas. It would be a great adventure. I think what is animating those crowds, the Edwardian era has been one of very, very partisan, conflicted politics. And I think those people, Sigmund Freud,
当人们谈论第一次世界大战的爆发时，人们很高兴。他们以为圣诞节前就能回家。这将是一场伟大的冒险。我认为激励那些人群的是，爱德华时代一直是一个非常、非常党派化、冲突不断的政治时代。我认为那些人，西格蒙德·弗洛伊德，
we quoted him a couple of episodes ago. People feel, you know, rather like, the only comparison I can think of in Britain in recent years, perhaps when COVID struck, perhaps when the Queen died, a genuine sense, for once, we're all together. All the silly divisions and squabbles are forgotten. And this is that, but magnified to an extraordinary degree. Now, the Kaiser comes in from the balcony and they're all sort of standing around discussing logistics.
我们几集前引用过他。人们感到，你知道，相当像，我能想到的英国近年来的唯一比较，也许是新冠疫情爆发时，也许是女王去世时，一种真正的感觉，有史以来，我们都在一起。所有愚蠢的分歧和争吵都被遗忘了。这就是那样，但被放大到了非凡的程度。现在，德皇从阳台上进来，他们都在讨论后勤问题。
And suddenly, Bethman Holbeck, the Chancellor, bursts into the room and he says, I have a telegram from London. And do you know what he calls it, Tom? It's a bombshell. A bombshell. It's an absolute bombshell. It changes everything.
突然，首相贝特曼-霍尔维格冲进房间，他说：“我收到了一封来自伦敦的电报。”你知道他称它为什么吗，汤姆？这是一个重磅炸弹。一个重磅炸弹。这是一个绝对的重磅炸弹。它改变了一切。
This is the greatest twist in world history, this bombshell, because they've had news from Prince Lichnowsky, the ambassador in London. Edward Grey has made up his mind. The British have decided and they will remain neutral. And not only that, absolutely beyond the Kaiser's wildest dreams, the British will not only stay out themselves, they will guarantee that France will stay out. And when the Germans hear this- Because that then means it's Russia against Germany. Russia against Germany and Austria. And indeed, Austria-Hungary. Yeah. It's all their dreams come true. The British are staying out. The French are staying out. The British will force the French to stay out, and they can deal with the Russians once and for all, and they will win.
这是世界历史上最伟大的转折，这个重磅炸弹，因为他们收到了伦敦大使利希诺夫斯基亲王的消息。爱德华·格雷已经拿定了主意。英国人已经决定，他们将保持中立。不仅如此，绝对超出了德皇最疯狂的梦想，英国人不仅自己会置身事外，他们还会保证法国也会置身事外。当德国人听到这个——因为这意味着是俄国对抗德国。俄国对抗德国和奥地利。确实，奥匈帝国。是的。这是他们梦想成真。英国人保持中立。法国人保持中立。英国人将强迫法国人保持中立，他们可以一劳永逸地对付俄国人，他们会赢。
Thank God for that. Peace in the West. The Kaiser is like a man possessed. He is so happy. He says to General von Moltke, stop the mobilization. Stop going westwards. Now, he says, we will marchke, stop the mobilisation. Stop going westwards. Now, he says, we will march the entire army to the east. And everybody's like, hurrah, and they're kind of, you know, clenching their fists and
感谢上帝。西方和平了。德皇就像一个被附身的人。他太高兴了。他对毛奇将军说：“停止动员。停止向西进军。现在，”他说，“我们将把整个军队向东进军。”每个人都像，“万岁”，他们有点，你知道，握紧拳头，
slap each other in the back. And presumably for Moltke, this is a kind of nightmare because he's got all his trains sorted out. Moltke, the description of him is that he was trembling. And he says in this sort of quiet voice i can't we can't and of course you can't as you said tom their entire plan is based on going westwards all their war games all their preparation is they will go west right now seven out of every eight soldiers in the german army is moving westwards their advanced troops have already crossed the border into Luxembourg. And as Molka says, if we stop now, first of all,
互相拍打背部。对于毛奇来说，这大概是一场噩梦，因为他已经安排好了所有的火车。对毛奇的描述是，他在颤抖。他用那种安静的声音说：“我不能，我们不能。”当然，你不能，正如你所说的，汤姆，他们的整个计划都是基于向西进军，他们所有的战争游戏，所有的准备都是他们将向西进军。现在，德国军队中每八名士兵中就有七名正在向西移动，他们的先头部队已经越过了卢森堡边境。正如毛奇所说，如果我们现在停止，首先，
the whole apparatus will fall apart. We'll have loads of trains going in the wrong direction. So like in Austria? Yes, yeah, right. We'll look like the Austrians. We'll have men standing around at stations with no food. It will be a complete shambles. It'll be like a British bank holiday.
整个机构就会崩溃。我们会有一堆火车往错误的方向开。就像在奥地利一样？是的，没错。我们会看起来像奥地利人。我们会让士兵站在车站里没有食物。这将是一场彻底的混乱。这就像一个英国银行假日。
But worse, it will leave our entire Western border with France totally undefended. The French will just walk in. And the Kaiser can't believe his ears that Molker is saying this. And he says to him, your illustrious uncle would have given me a different answer. Now, this is von Molker, the elder, the man in whose shadow Moltke, the younger, has lived for so long. And Moltke at that, I mean, it sounds bizarre. He basically breaks down and starts crying. As he says later, I thought my heart would break. I was broken and shed tears of despair. And the war minister, Erich von Falkenhayn, has to take him aside to console him because he is crying to be humiliated like this in front of everybody else.
但更糟糕的是，它将使我们与法国的整个西部边境完全失去防御。法国人会直接走进来。德皇不敢相信自己的耳朵，毛奇竟然这么说。他对他说：“你杰出的叔叔会给我一个不同的答案。”现在，这是老毛奇，小毛奇长期生活在他的阴影下。毛奇在那一刻，我的意思是，这听起来很离奇。他基本上崩溃了，开始哭泣。正如他后来所说：“我以为我的心会碎。我崩溃了，流下了绝望的泪水。”战争大臣埃里希·冯·法尔肯海恩不得不把他拉到一边安慰他，因为他在其他人面前哭得如此丢人。
And his whole plan is falling apart. He sees the French walking in. He's in floods of tears. He actually has to leave the palace and he's basically sent home. The man who commands the German war machine, as he's taken out, he's saying to people, I was happy to fight the French and the Russians. I can't fight the Kaiser asaiser as well this is mad he goes home still crying and when he gets home he seems to have had either a breakdown or his wife later believed he had a stroke he had a minor stroke it's very like viviani the french prime minister having a breakdown yeah cracking people sobbing having breakdowns left right and center exactly that now meanwhile mulch has gone in the palace fulkenheim the war minister says look we'll say to the british we have to keep moving the troops left, right and centre. Exactly that. Now, meanwhile, Moltke's gone. In the palace,
他的整个计划正在瓦解。他看到法国人走了进来。他泪流满面。他实际上不得不离开宫殿，基本上被送回了家。这位指挥德国战争机器的人，在被带走时，他对人们说，我很高兴与法国人和俄国人作战。我不能同时与凯撒作战，这太疯狂了，他哭着回家了，当他回到家时，他似乎要么是崩溃了，要么是他的妻子后来认为他中风了，他轻微中风了，这非常像法国总理维维亚尼崩溃了，是的，人们在崩溃，到处都在哭泣，完全就是这样，与此同时，毛奇已经进入了宫殿，战争部长法尔肯海恩说，看，我们会告诉英国人，我们必须继续向左、向右、向中心移动军队。完全就是这样。现在，与此同时，毛奇已经走了。在宫殿里，
Falkenhayn, the war minister, says, look, we'll say to the British, we have to keep moving the troops westward for the reasons that von Moltke has explained, but they won't fire a shot. For a few days, they will stay immobile while we sort out the details of this formal deal with Britain and Britain will keep the French out of the war. And the Kaiser is already getting to work on his telegram to George V, monarch to monarch, cousin to cousin. I am absolutely thrilled with this deal. I'm delighted. Thank you so much. Now we have to keep moving the men west. But he says, and I quote, the troops on my frontier are in the act. Right now we are stopping them by telegraph and telephone from crossing into France. Let's sort this out. Brilliant. This is what we've always wanted. So Dominic, this seems to be very, very substantive evidence that the German high
战争部长法尔肯海恩说，看，我们会告诉英国人，出于冯·毛奇解释的原因，我们必须继续向西移动军队，但他们不会开一枪。几天之内，他们将保持不动，而我们处理与英国这项正式协议的细节，英国将使法国远离战争。凯撒已经在起草他给乔治五世的电报了，君主对君主，表亲对表亲。我对这项协议绝对感到兴奋。我很高兴。非常感谢。现在我们必须继续向西移动军队。但他引用说，我边境上的军队正在行动。现在我们正通过电报和电话阻止他们进入法国。让我们解决这个问题。太棒了。这正是我们一直想要的。所以多米尼克，这似乎是非常、非常有力的证据，表明德国最高
command and the Kaiser has not been planning and wanting a war of aggression. Isn't it? I mean, if he's this happy, he's been given his war and now he's celebrating the fact that it seems to have been cancelled at the last minute. If you were critical of the Kaiser, I suppose you would say he's just panicked at the last minute and blinked. I think if you were being more sympathetic, you would say, yes, he never really wanted a war with Britain. He wants to be taken seriously by the British. But with France as well. Yeah, I think they don't mind fighting France. I think they'd be quite happy to fight the French.
统帅部和凯撒并没有计划和想要一场侵略战争。不是吗？我的意思是，如果他这么高兴，他已经得到了他的战争，现在他正在庆祝它似乎在最后一刻被取消的事实。如果你对凯撒持批评态度，我想你会说他只是在最后一刻惊慌失措并退缩了。我想如果你更同情他，你会说，是的，他从来没有真正想过与英国开战。他希望被英国人认真对待。但也包括法国。是的，我认为他们不介意与法国作战。我认为他们会很高兴与法国人作战。
But the thought of fighting the Russians on their own, brilliant. And a great relief, right? You're about to fight a world war and you're told half of your opponents are no longer in the ring. What a tremendous relief that is. If you really want to fight the French, deal with them afterwards. But you can deal with the Russians right now. I personally think, for all that the Kaiser ranted and raved about the British, he never really wanted to fight them. I think this is the perfect example of this. And actually, you know, what really bears your point out is that was what he does now. He calls for champagne and he says, I want my family around me. We're having champagne. Let's go to the garden. Oh, his garden again. I love the fact he loves his gardens.
但想到要独自与俄国人作战，太棒了。这是一种巨大的解脱，对吧？你即将进行一场世界大战，却被告知你的一半对手已经不在擂台上了。那是多么巨大的解脱啊。如果你真的想和法国人打，事后再处理他们。但你现在就可以处理俄国人了。我个人认为，尽管凯撒对英国人大发雷霆，但他从来没有真正想过要与他们作战。我认为这就是完美的例子。实际上，你知道，真正证明你观点的是他现在所做的事情。他要了香槟，说，我希望我的家人在我身边。我们要喝香槟。我们去花园吧。哦，又是他的花园。我喜欢他热爱花园这一点。
He's doing that, I think, out of a sense of relief. Just enormous burden has been lifted that he will no longer have to fight the British. Now, a lot of popular histories say when war was declared with Russia, the Kaiser called for champagne to celebrate it. In other words, they condense the story and they miss the fact that actually the champagne is being served really to celebrate the neutrality of the British. So the Kaiser, I mean, he's had his ups and downs in this story. Yeah. But this is the up of ups. It is a transcendently joyful moment that the British have blinked. They're going to compel the French to blink as well. But even as he's drinking his champagne, Tom, another twist is in store. Well, should we have a break at this point?
我想他这样做是出于一种解脱感。沉重的负担终于卸下了，他不再需要与英国人作战了。现在，许多通俗历史书说，当对俄宣战时，凯撒要了香槟来庆祝。换句话说，他们浓缩了故事，却忽略了这样一个事实：香槟实际上主要是为了庆祝英国的中立。所以凯撒，我的意思是，他在这个故事中经历了大起大落。是的。但这可是大起中的大起。这是一个极其欢乐的时刻，英国人退缩了。他们也将迫使法国人退缩。但就在他喝香槟的时候，汤姆，另一个转折正在酝酿之中。好吧，我们现在休息一下吗？
And people listening, when we come back, you will find out whether Britain does keep out of the First World War or not. So amazing revelations to come. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment
听众朋友们，当我们回来时，你们会发现英国是否真的置身于第一次世界大战之外。所以精彩的揭秘即将到来。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的来源。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的帷幕
and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of the entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com hello welcome back to the rest is history the final part of our epic series on how Europe went to war. We left you on a cliffhanger. The Kaiser seems to have received a telegram from George V basically saying that Britain is going to keep out of the war and that the British will pressurise the French to stay neutral as well. And so the Kaiser has cracked open the champagne to toast this and to toast the fact that he won't be fighting a war on two fronts.
并告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com，也就是therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《剩下的就是历史》，这是我们关于欧洲如何走向战争的史诗系列节目的最后一部分。我们留给你们一个悬念。凯撒似乎收到了一封来自乔治五世的电报，基本上说英国将置身于战争之外，英国也将向法国施压，要求他们保持中立。所以凯撒打开了香槟来庆祝这一点，并庆祝他不必在两条战线上作战的事实。
He's only got to fight the Russians. So he's sipping his champagne and then Dominic, another telegram arrives. And this is also from George V. And George V has wired, I think there must be some misunderstanding as to a suggestion that passed in friendly conversation between Prince Lichnowsky and Sir Edward Grey this afternoon when they were discussing how actual fighting between German and French armies might be avoided. And basically, the Kaiser's got the wrong end of the stick. Yeah. There is no such British offer. It's not really the Kaiser's fault though, Tom.
他只需要与俄国人作战。所以他正在啜饮香槟，然后多米尼克，另一封电报到了。这也是来自乔治五世的。乔治五世发电报说，我想对于今天下午利希诺夫斯基亲王和爱德华·格雷爵士在友好交谈中提出的关于如何避免德法军队之间实际战斗的建议，一定存在某种误解。基本上，凯撒完全搞错了。是的。根本没有这样的英国提议。不过，这并不是凯撒的错，汤姆。
He's been misinformed. That's the truth of it. So what exactly has happened? What seems to have happened, it's still a bit of a mystery actually, and there are whole sort of academic journal articles about exactly what happened. I think what happened was that the German ambassador to Britain, you described him earlier and you said what a brilliant fellow you thought he was because the German ambassador to Britain, you described him earlier and you said what a brilliant fellow you thought he was because he was so anglophile. Very anglophile.
他被误导了。事实就是如此。那么到底发生了什么？似乎发生的事情，实际上仍然是一个谜，关于到底发生了什么，有整整一类学术期刊文章。我想发生的事情是，德国驻英国大使，你之前描述过他，你说你认为他是一个多么出色的人，因为德国驻英国大使，你之前描述过他，你说你认为他是一个多么出色的人，因为他非常亲英。非常亲英。
Prince Lichnowsky. Yeah. He's too anglophile. He's too anglophile. And he's basically cooked up a deal himself with Grey's secretary, probably Sir William Tyrrell. And they said, well, wouldn't it be great if the Germans didn't attack France and then we could be neutral? We could maybe persuade the French to hold back. And they've somehow convinced themselves that this is a tangible thing. And they've sent the proposal to Berlin. It's worth pointing out, isn't it, that Litnovsky, when he goes back to Berlin,
利希诺夫斯基亲王。是的。他太亲英了。他太亲英了。他基本上自己和格雷的秘书，可能是威廉·泰瑞尔爵士，策划了一项交易。他们说，如果德国人不攻击法国，那不是很好吗？然后我们就可以中立了。我们也许可以说服法国人克制。他们不知何故说服了自己，这是一个切实可行的事情。他们把这个提议发到了柏林。值得指出的是，不是吗，利希诺夫斯基，当他回到柏林时，
will actually write reports on his time in London and the buildup to the war and Germany's plans after war has been declared that will form the basis of the entire case that Germany was kind of willfully warmongering. Yes, he will indeed. Lichnowsky feels betrayed by the Germans. He has gone so native in London that he can't believe that they're backing Austria so keenly. He can't believe they weren't prepared to accept Gray's mediation plan. And he can't believe that now they are mobilizing, they are preparing and all of this kind of thing. And he blames, he says there was a war party in Berlin, which I don't think is quite right. There was a
实际上会写关于他在伦敦的时光、战争的酝酿以及德国在宣战后的计划的报告，这些报告将构成德国是蓄意挑起战争的整个案件的基础。是的，他确实会。利希诺夫斯基感到被德国人背叛了。他在伦敦变得如此本土化，以至于他无法相信他们如此热衷于支持奥地利。他无法相信他们不准备接受格雷的调解计划。他无法相信现在他们正在动员，他们正在准备，诸如此类的事情。他指责，他说柏林有一个战争党，我觉得这不太对。有一个
party that was definitely happy to accept the challenge if they felt it was offered. But whether they wanted to start a world war in the summer of 1914, I think most historians would say they didn't want to. Now, maybe you can blame them and say that their recklessness or their insouciance, their irresponsibility was a large part of what went wrong. But I don't think Likunovsky is right that they engineered it as it were. But it's undoubtedly true. This deal that the Kaiser thinks he's about to sign with his cousin just doesn't exist. And when he gets that telegram from george v he's been drinking champagne emotions have been so high and he's such a voluble volatile man his disappointment
党派如果觉得受到挑战，绝对乐于接受。但他们是否想在1914年夏天发动世界大战，我想大多数历史学家会说他们不想。现在，也许你可以责怪他们，说他们的鲁莽或漫不经心、不负责任是导致出错的很大一部分原因。但我不认为利希诺夫斯基说他们策划了这一切是正确的。但毫无疑问，凯撒认为他即将与表亲签署的这项协议根本不存在。当他收到乔治五世的那封电报时，他一直在喝香槟，情绪非常高涨，他是一个如此健谈、反复无常的人，他的失望
is total he is ranting and raving he says grey must be mad or an idiot a false dog who is afraid of his own baseness so this is potentially very bad news for the squirrels of Northumberland. Yes, I suppose so, because they're what the Germans will shoot. Are they, is it? Yes, to bring grey to heel. So the Kaiser is devastated and it's like the air has gone out of his party. And von Moltke, who's back at home having either a stroke or a breakdown, is brought back to the palace at midnight and he's shown into the imperial bedchamber.
是彻底的。他大发雷霆，他说格雷一定是疯了或者是个白痴，一条害怕自己卑鄙行径的假狗。所以这对诺森伯兰郡的松鼠来说可能是非常坏的消息。是的，我想是的，因为那是德国人会射击的目标。是吗，是吗？是的，为了让格雷就范。所以凯撒崩溃了，就像他的派对气氛全无一样。而回到家要么中风要么崩溃的冯·毛奇在午夜被带回宫殿，被带进了帝国卧室。
And there is the Kaiser, presumably not in a dressing gown like his cousin, but in full uniform. I imagine he goes to bed in a breastplate. Yeah, definitely. And he waves the telegram of George V at him, points and says to von Moltke, look at this, now you can do what you want, as in, sod the British. So the Kaiser finally goes to bed. They all go to bed.
凯撒就在那里，大概不像他的表亲那样穿着睡袍，而是穿着全套制服。我想象他穿着胸甲睡觉。是的，绝对。他向他挥舞着乔治五世的电报，指着它对冯·毛奇说，看看这个，现在你可以做你想做的事了，意思是，去他的英国人。所以凯撒终于上床睡觉了。他们都去睡觉了。
Early the next morning, let's start the next morning in London, Sunday, the 2nd of August. Lichnowsky, whose scheme seems to have failed, goes to 10 Downing Street. And he is a broken man. He is crying, all of this stuff. So yet more tears, ambassadorial tears. He goes to see Asquith and he says, please, please don't side with France. Germany will be crushed, will be overwhelmed. He was very agitated, poor man, and wept, wrote Asquith afterwards. But Asquith then says,
第二天一大早，让我们从伦敦的第二天早上开始，8月2日星期日。利希诺夫斯基，他的计划似乎失败了，去了唐宁街10号。他是一个破碎的人。他在哭泣，所有这些事情。所以又是更多的眼泪，大使的眼泪。他去见阿斯奎斯，说，请，请不要站在法国一边。德国会被粉碎，会被压垮。他非常激动，可怜的人，后来阿斯奎斯写道。但阿斯奎斯随后说，
I told him we had no desire to intervene and it's up to the Germans. If they don't invade Belgium, if they don't send their fleet into the channel to attack the unprotected north coast of France, then we will stand aside. Now, of course, he's basically asking the Germans not to fight in the West, and it's hard to see that they're not going to do that. But we'll come to that in due course. And later on that Sunday, Margot Asquith goes to see the Lichnowskis. The princess was in tears on the sofa, and he was walking up and down in silence. He called me by the hand and said, oh, say there is not going to be war. Dear, dear Mrs. Asquith, can we not stop it? I put my arms around Mechtild on the sofa and we both cried. Actually, I've been a bit harsh there by doing that voice.
我告诉他我们无意干预，这取决于德国人。如果他们不入侵比利时，如果他们不把舰队派往海峡去攻击法国毫无防备的北海岸，那么我们就会袖手旁观。现在，当然，他基本上是在要求德国人不要在西线作战，很难看出他们不会那样做。但我们会在适当的时候谈到这一点。那天晚些时候，玛戈·阿斯奎斯去见利希诺夫斯基夫妇。公主在沙发上流泪，他沉默地走来走去。他拉着我的手说，哦，说不会有战争。亲爱的，亲爱的阿斯奎斯夫人，我们不能阻止它吗？我把双臂搂住沙发上的梅希尔德，我们都哭了。其实，我那样模仿声音有点苛刻了。
I think you have because that's a very, very affecting moment. Yeah, it is a sad scene, but that's the cynicism of the man, Tom. That's the Captain Benteen cynicism that people associate breaking through yeah can't help myself yeah the show of compassion
我想你是，因为那是一个非常、非常感人的时刻。是的，这是一个悲伤的场景，但那是那个人的愤世嫉俗，汤姆。那是人们联想到的本廷上尉的愤世嫉俗，突破了，是的，我无法自拔，是的，那种同情心的表现
beneath it a harsh cool calculating heart yes a cruel and cynical intelligence I believe that's right
在那之下是一颗冷酷、冷静、算计的心，是的，一颗残忍而愤世嫉俗的智慧，我相信那是对的
that's the phrase so across Europe generally now the mood is is awful actually it's not all celebrations so the news has spread
这就是那句话，所以现在整个欧洲的气氛实际上很糟糕，并不是所有的庆祝活动，所以消息已经传开了
that the great powers not yet britain of course but the great powers are at war going to war and actually three examples that give the lie to the idea of the the great celebrations the preeminent german kind of bourgeois middle class newspaper the day was the frankfurter's item over everything hangs a great gravity in their quiet rooms wives and young women sit nursing their somber thoughts about the immediate future great fear of terrible things of what may be to come that's the mood in germany in austria in alexander watson's brilliant book ring of steel which is all about germany and austria in the first world war he quotes a priest from the town of yablunkov which was in austrian silesia and the priest wrote in his diary that when the mobilization orders were put up.
大国，当然还不是英国，但大国正在开战，即将开战，实际上有三个例子反驳了那种大肆庆祝的想法，德国首屈一指的资产阶级中产阶级报纸《法兰克福日报》上写道，一切都笼罩在一种巨大的沉重感中。在安静的房间里，妻子和年轻女性坐着，怀着对不久将来的阴郁想法，对可怕的事情、对可能发生的事情的巨大恐惧，这就是德国的气氛。在奥地利，在亚历山大·沃森的杰作《钢铁之环》中，这本书全是关于第一次世界大战中的德国和奥地利，他引用了奥地利西里西亚亚布伦科夫镇一位牧师的话，这位牧师在日记中写道，当动员令贴出来时。
So Austria has now mobilized. Austria, exactly. Austria is now joining the campaign. The people poured into the marketplace. Everyone realized that the situation was dangerous or was seized by a strange fear of the unknown, great and threatening. And there's a story that people will remember who have read Chris Clark's great bestseller, The Sleepwalkers. At the end of that book, at the very end, he describes a town in the French Alps called Vatilia.
所以奥地利现在已经动员了。奥地利，没错。奥地利现在加入了这场运动。人们涌入市场。每个人都意识到局势很危险，或者被一种对未知的、巨大的、威胁性的奇怪恐惧所笼罩。有一个故事，读过克里斯·克拉克那本畅销书《梦游者》的人会记得。在那本书的结尾，在最后，他描述了法国阿尔卑斯山一个叫瓦蒂利亚的小镇。
And it's an account from a schoolmaster, the town schoolmaster. And he said, basically, they're ringing a bell, a tocsin, to bring people in from the fields. Because, of course, most people in France, as in Germany, as in Russia, were peasants at this point. They worked in their land. And they come in and they're all still carrying their pitchforks. And the schoolmaster wrote, what can it mean? What was going to happen to us? Asked the women. Wives, children, husbands, all were overcome by emotion. The wives clung to the arms of their husbands. The children, seeing their mothers weeping, started to cry too.
这是一个校长的叙述，镇上的校长。他说，基本上，他们在敲钟，警钟，把人们从田野里叫回来。因为当然，法国的大多数人，就像德国和俄国一样，当时都是农民。他们在自己的土地上工作。他们进来了，手里还拿着干草叉。校长写道，这意味着什么？我们要发生什么事了？女人们问。妻子、孩子、丈夫，都被情绪淹没了。妻子们紧紧抓住丈夫的手臂。孩子们看到母亲在哭泣，也开始哭泣。
All around us was alarm and consternation. So this idea that people didn't know is not right. They knew. I mean, I think that that's something that we've traced throughout the course of this series, you know, and why they're not sleepwalkers. I mean, even in Britain, Tom, which has not yet joined the war, there's a wonderful book about 1914 called The Fateful Year by Mark Bostridge. Oh, yeah. The biographer of Florence Nightingale.
我们周围一片惊慌和沮丧。所以这种认为人们不知道的想法是不对的。他们知道。我的意思是，我认为这是我们在整个系列节目中一直追踪的东西，你知道，为什么他们不是梦游者。我的意思是，即使在英国，汤姆，还没有加入战争，有一本关于1914年的精彩书籍，叫马克·博斯特里奇写的《命运之年》。哦，是的。弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔的传记作者。
And he describes in that the Sunday sermons given by vicars. Some of them, I mean, there's one bloke. If you've gone to St Mary's New Market that Sunday, the rector said, no town in England is safe. At night, it may be turned into a smouldering ruin and its inhabitants into blackened corpses. I think that is a man who has been reading HG Wells. It is. And that's the sort of thing I look for, actually, in the Church of England. And you don't get any more, do you?
他在书中描述了牧师们在周日布道时所说的话。他们中的一些人，我的意思是，有一个家伙。如果你那个周日去了新市场圣玛丽教堂，牧师说，英国没有一个城镇是安全的。在夜里，它可能会变成一片闷烧的废墟，居民会变成焦黑的尸体。我认为那是一个读过赫伯特·乔治·威尔斯作品的人。确实是。这正是我在英国国教中寻找的东西。你再也听不到了，不是吗？
No. It's all very much about inclusivity and not enough about smouldering towns. Not enough apocalyptic foreboding. Right, exactly. So, unusually, extraordinarily, the cabinet is meeting on a Sunday yet again. Outside in Trafalgar Square, there's a huge anti-war demonstration addressed by the great sort of founding figure, the Leonine figure of the Labour Party, Keir Hardie,
不。现在全是关于包容性，而关于闷烧城镇的内容不够多。末日预兆不够多。对，没错。所以，不同寻常的是，非同寻常的是，内阁又在周日开会了。在特拉法尔加广场外，有一场巨大的反战示威，由工党的伟大奠基人、狮子般的人物凯尔·哈迪发表讲话，
who is against the war. After whom Keir Starmer is named. After whom Keir Starmer is named, exactly. And they all gather. They know that the Tories support the war. So if they split and the result is a Tory government, then Britain will go to war anyway. And is anxiety about the Tories coming to power also anxiety about what the impact of that might
他反对战争。凯尔·斯塔默就是以他的名字命名的。凯尔·斯塔默就是以他的名字命名的，没错。他们都聚集在一起。他们知道保守党支持战争。所以如果他们分裂，结果是保守党政府，那么英国无论如何都会参战。对保守党上台的焦虑，是否也是对那可能产生的影响的焦虑
be on Ireland? Is that any kind of influence on British thinking? That is a really good question. And I think it disappears. I think they've only got room in their heads for one thing. Right. So we quoted Churchill earlier, didn't we, saying that the spires of Tyrone and Fermanagh faded into the drizzle of the Irish mist or something. The murk of Ireland. Yeah, exactly. And I think that's exactly right, that they've been obsessed with Ireland for the last, what, three, four years?
在爱尔兰？这对英国的思考有什么影响吗？这是一个非常好的问题。我认为它消失了。我认为他们的脑子里只能装下一件事。对。所以我们之前引用了丘吉尔的话，不是吗，说泰隆和弗马纳的尖塔消失在爱尔兰薄雾的细雨中还是什么的。爱尔兰的阴霾。是的，没错。我认为这完全正确，他们过去三四年一直沉迷于爱尔兰问题？
And now their minds have turned to Belgium and they've only got room in their heads for one thing. So they happen to meet, 11 o'clock. And Grey says, look, we've had a load of meetings. And as the time has come, he says for plain speaking, war is coming. And I don't believe we can afford to see France crushed. We have led France to rely upon us unless we support her. In her agony, I cannot continue at the Foreign Office. I mean, finally, finally, his cards are on the table. And the amazing thing is that even at this point, don't forget no German has yet entered Belgium. Even at this point, most of the Liberal cabinet do not agree. So on the point of Britain's honour, they could have said, well, this is Gray. He's been
现在他们的心思转向了比利时，他们的脑子里只能装下一件事。所以他们碰巧在11点开会。格雷说，看，我们已经开了不少会了。他说现在是直言不讳的时候了，战争即将来临。我不相信我们能承受看到法国被粉碎。我们引导法国依赖我们，除非我们支持她。在她痛苦的时候，我无法继续在外交部工作。我的意思是，终于，终于，他的底牌摊开了。令人惊奇的是，即使在这一点上，别忘了还没有德国人进入比利时。即使在这一点上，大多数自由党内阁成员也不赞同。所以就英国的荣誉而言，他们本可以说，好吧，这是格雷。他一直
underhand. He's been a loose cannon. As a man of principle, he will now have to resign. Fine. Yeah, they could have done that. Cabinet collective responsibility does not hold. We don't have to do this. They absolutely could have done that. And some people, deep down, probably would quite like to have done, I think. But probably a slight majority of the Cabinet, even at this point,
鬼鬼祟祟。他一直是个不受控制的人。作为一个有原则的人，他现在必须辞职。好吧。是的，他们本可以那样做。内阁集体责任制并不成立。我们不必这样做。他们绝对可以那样做。有些人，内心深处，可能很想那样做，我想。但即使在这一点上，内阁中可能有一小部分多数人
are thinking to let France down, to see the Germans on the channel. It's a risk. It is, I mean, quite apart from the question of honour. But in what way is it different to the Franco-Prussian war? It's a very good question. We will be doing a special bonus episode, won't we, where we'll be looking at some of these deeper questions. It is a very good question. In what way is it different? I think the difference to them is that the threat of the reality of germany to them now in 1914 is immeasurably greater than the threat or reality of prussia in 1870 is it also that belgian question that if they're going into belgium they're going into the low countries the low countries has always been felt by the british as their yeah you can't have an alien power, a hostile power in the Low Countries. People always go on about the mouth of the river Scheldt, a key thing for British strategy.
在考虑让法国失望，看到德国人在海峡。这是一种风险。我的意思是，撇开荣誉问题不谈。但这与普法战争有什么不同？这是一个非常好的问题。我们将制作一期特别的额外剧集，不是吗，我们将探讨其中一些更深层次的问题。这是一个非常好的问题。它有什么不同？我认为对他们来说的区别在于，1914年德国对他们的现实威胁，比1870年普鲁士的威胁或现实要大得多。这也是比利时问题吗，如果他们进入比利时，他们就进入了低地国家，低地国家一直被英国人认为是他们的，是的，你不能让一个敌对势力、一个敌对国家控制低地国家。人们总是谈论斯海尔德河口，这是英国战略的关键。
And they say, we've never allowed a hostile power to control the Scheldt, or at least not since Great Britain existed in 1707. That's actually not really true. So Napoleon obviously controlled it. Yeah, sure. But they have convinced themselves, a lot of them, that strategically it's impossible. It will mean death to the British empire if somebody controls this. And of course, Germany in 1914 is a different prospect than Germany in 1870, precisely because
他们说，我们从未允许敌对势力控制斯海尔德河，或者至少在1707年大不列颠存在以来没有。这其实并不完全正确。所以拿破仑显然控制了它。是的，当然。但他们已经说服了自己，他们中的许多人，从战略上讲这是不可能的。如果有人控制了这一点，对大英帝国来说意味着死亡。当然，1914年的德国与1870年的德国前景不同，恰恰是因为
it is such a huge industrial and economic powerhouse in a way that it wasn't even in 1870. So the stakes seem very high to them, I think. And don't forget, I think that mood that we've talked about so much in this story of fatalism, of a dread of disintegration and decline, that seems so overwrought in many ways. The British have been reading all the same books that the Germans and the Austrians have, and they have this same, it's now or never, the clock is ticking, the hour is dark, all that kind of stuff. And the British, likewise, have been very divided among themselves. And so maybe a war will help everyone to get back together again.
它是一个巨大的工业和经济强国，这在1870年甚至还不是这样。所以对他们来说，赌注似乎非常高，我想。别忘了，我认为我们在故事中谈论了那么多的那种宿命论情绪，那种对瓦解和衰落的恐惧，在许多方面看起来都太夸张了。英国人读过德国人和奥地利人读过的所有书，他们也有同样的感觉，现在或永不，时钟在滴答作响，时刻是黑暗的，诸如此类。同样，英国人内部也非常分裂。所以也许一场战争会帮助每个人重新团结起来。
Right, exactly. So that first meeting breaks up and now Edward Grey does what, I still can't quite get my head around, it does seem like the most Edwardian thing that's ever happened and ever would happen. I admire this so much yeah because he goes to the zoo doesn't he to look at the birds he does he goes out on a walk he walks around the demonstration and he bumps into a friend and he says uh yeah i've got a spare arm i'm going out of the zoo yeah but you make it sound like this is this is a mad thing to do. But I think that walking,
对，没错。所以第一次会议解散了，现在爱德华·格雷做了什么，我仍然无法理解，这看起来确实是发生过和可能发生的最爱德华时代的事情。我非常钦佩这一点，是的，因为他去了动物园，不是吗，去看鸟。他确实去了，他出去散步，他在示威游行周围走动，他碰到了一个朋友，他说，呃，是的，我有一个空闲的下午，我要去动物园，是的，但你把它说得好像这是一件疯狂的事情。但我认为散步，
clearing your head, not staying in a stuffy office where everyone is panicking, walking, but also kind of surrounding yourself with the beauties of the natural world, the wonders of the natural world, maybe provides a sense of perspective. I don't know. I think you're being very generous. No, I disagree because I think that listening to Birdsong, for instance, I think it does have a calming effect. Yeah, fine. I think it can kind of ease anxieties, nightmares. It can bring clarity. Okay.
清空你的头脑，不要待在一个每个人都在恐慌的闷热办公室里，散步，同时也用自然界的美丽、自然界的奇迹包围自己，也许能提供一种视角。我不知道。我认为你太慷慨了。不，我不同意，因为我认为听鸟鸣，例如，我认为它确实有镇静作用。是的，好吧。我认为它可以缓解焦虑、噩梦。它可以带来清晰。好吧。
Well, Edward Gray joining us there on the podcast. So I'm completely with Sir Edward on that. Yeah, of course. I mean, you know, we all know where you stand on Sir Edward Gray, Tom. So off he goes to the zoo. He communes with his birds. And then at 6.30 that afternoon, they meet again. Now they actually are reaching an agreement.
好吧，爱德华·格雷加入了我们的播客。所以我完全支持爱德华爵士。是的，当然。我的意思是，你知道，我们都知道你对爱德华·格雷爵士的立场，汤姆。所以他去了动物园。他与他的鸟儿交流。然后在那天下午6点30分，他们再次会面。现在他们实际上正在达成一致。
The longer it goes on, actually, the more they meet, the more they move towards Gray's position because he is so stubborn and they are more pliable. And actually, by now, it's obvious that Belgium is going to be a massive issue. And I think it's Thomas Otte in his book, July Crisis, says, what a perfect issue for the liberals. Because the liberals are, of course, the do-gooding party in British politics. They are the party of an ethical foreign policy, international law. Prune juice.
时间拖得越长，实际上，他们开会越多，他们就越向格雷的立场靠拢，因为他太固执了，而他们更顺从。实际上，到现在为止，很明显比利时将成为一个巨大的问题。我想是托马斯·奥特在他的书《七月危机》中说，这对自由党来说是一个多么完美的问题。因为自由党当然是英国政治中行善的政党。他们是道德外交政策、国际法的政党。西梅汁。
And, yeah, vegetarianism, whatever. If you said to them, let's go to war because it's in Britain's interests to defend our ally, to preserve our empire, they'd be a little bit jittery about it. If you said, let's go to war, even if it's against our interests, but to uphold international law, they'd be like, oh, brilliant. Can't wait. Pile in. Sort of feed it into my veins or whatever. Yeah. So on this, the Belgium issue is really, really crucial. And now the Germans make probably, I would say the single most ludicrous error, the worst error that anybody made in this entire crisis. Don't forget, the British had discussed the Germans going into Belgium, and they'd said,
还有，是的，素食主义，随便什么。如果你对他们说，让我们去打仗吧，因为保卫我们的盟友、维护我们的帝国符合英国的利益，他们会对此有点紧张。如果你说，让我们去打仗吧，即使这违背了我们的利益，但为了维护国际法，他们会说，哦，太棒了。等不及了。加入吧。把它注入我的血管什么的。是的。所以在这个问题上，比利时问题真的非常关键。现在德国人犯了，我会说，整个危机中任何人犯下的最荒谬的错误，最严重的错误。别忘了，英国人讨论过德国人进入比利时，他们说，
if they just go through the bottom, there's not much we're really going to do about it, realistically. What they do is that evening, their ambassador in Brussels gives the Belgians an ultimatum. Now, they could have gone through, but the reason they didn't was because the German foreign officer said, we can't take the risk of the British getting involved. We have to try to forestall it. Basically, we have to persuade the Belgians to give us a deal and to let us through. So it's a completely counterproductive move. Totally. They say it's the only way to stop the British getting involved. And of course, it's the one way that guarantees they will. And the ultimatum says, Sir Beltham says, the French are planning to attack us. I'm dreadfully sorry. We will be as quick as we can. We'll reimburse you for anything we eat as we come through. And we'll recompense you for the damage. But on the other hand, if you say no, we will crush you and king albert you know straight away he says well there's no way i'm
如果他们只是穿过底部，我们实际上不会做太多事情。他们所做的是那天晚上，他们在布鲁塞尔的大使向比利时人发出了最后通牒。现在，他们本可以穿过去，但他们没有这样做是因为德国外交部说，我们不能冒英国卷入的风险。我们必须设法阻止它。基本上，我们必须说服比利时人与我们达成协议，让我们通过。所以这是一个完全适得其反的举动。完全是。他们说这是阻止英国卷入的唯一方法。当然，这是保证他们会卷入的唯一方法。最后通牒说，贝尔瑟姆爵士说，法国人正计划攻击我们。我非常抱歉。我们会尽快。我们通过时吃掉的任何东西都会赔偿你们。我们会赔偿你们的损失。但另一方面，如果你说不，我们会粉碎你们，阿尔贝国王你知道，他立刻说，好吧，我绝不会
going to accept this you know we can't allow ourselves to just be a puppet of germany and he's made up his mind even as night falls on that sunday so now we come to monday the third of august which is a very famous day in british history because as luck would have it it's a bank holiday it is the bank holiday so dominic we began i mean not just this series but the series before yeah the episodes we did on the assassination in sarajevo with philip larkin's famous poem yeah which name checks people queuing up to get into the oval yeah your favorite sports ground which is my favorite cricket ground my favorite sports ground so the cricket ground that is home to surrey county cricket club who at this point are leading the county championship the championship between the
接受这个，你知道，我们不能让自己仅仅成为德国的傀儡，即使在那个周日的夜晚降临时，他也已经下定了决心。所以现在我们来到8月3日星期一，这在英国历史上是非常著名的一天，因为幸运的是，这是一个银行假日，确实是银行假日。所以多米尼克，我们开始，我的意思是，不仅是这个系列，还有之前的系列，是的，我们在萨拉热窝暗杀事件中做的剧集，提到了菲利普·拉金那首著名的诗，是的，提到了人们排队进入椭圆球场，是的，你最喜欢的运动场，这是我最喜欢的板球场，我最喜欢的运动场。所以那个板球场是萨里郡板球俱乐部的所在地，他们此时在郡锦标赛中领先，锦标赛在
various cricketing counties doing tremendously well and they are playing that day at the oval yeah against nottinghamshire 15 000 people queue up to watch the match jack hobbs the greatest batsman in england playing for surrey he scores a century. Surrey rack up an enormous total. It's golden age stuff. Great sportsmen. The Corinthian spirit. The green turf, all that kind of thing. But what the Surrey authorities do not know, and what the crowds watching that cricket match do not know, is that the War Office has already made plans to requisition the Oval for the war effort. For what?
各个板球郡之间进行，表现非常出色，他们那天在椭圆球场比赛，是的，对阵诺丁汉郡。15000人排队观看比赛，杰克·霍布斯，英格兰最伟大的击球手，为萨里队效力，他得了一百分。萨里队积累了巨大的总分。这是黄金时代的东西。伟大的运动员。科林斯精神。绿色的草坪，所有这些东西。但萨里当局不知道的是，观看那场板球比赛的观众不知道的是，战争部已经制定了征用椭圆球场用于战争努力的计划。为了什么？
It's designed to be a place where they will practice bayonetting. Oh, God. Right. So in the event, it's only requisitioned for two weeks, but that is enough to finish off the cricket season at the Oval. Well, that's sad. Cricket was the loser, Tom. But not Surrey, because although the championship gets cancelled, they are awarded it. Oh, that's nice. They win the championship for the first time in the 20th century right so
它被设计成一个他们练习刺刀的地方。哦，天哪。对。所以最终，它只被征用了两周，但这足以结束椭圆球场的板球赛季。好吧，那很悲伤。板球是输家，汤姆。但萨里不是，因为虽然锦标赛被取消了，但他们被授予了冠军。哦，那很好。他们20世纪第一次赢得冠军。对，所以
uh summer of 1914 not all bad so the larkin poem gives the impression as all recollections of the summer of 1914 do that it's a lovely sunny day great summer's weather all that kind of thing and that's true but only in the south of england the rest of the country was actually typical august bank holiday in other other words, it rained. And actually on the 5th of August, the match against Nottinghamshire gets rained off. Oh, wow. There you go. So the rain sweeps in.
呃，1914年的夏天并不全是坏事。所以拉金的诗给人一种印象，就像所有对1914年夏天的回忆一样，那是一个可爱的晴天，伟大的夏季天气，所有这些东西，这是真的，但只在英格兰南部。全国其他地区实际上是典型的八月银行假日，换句话说，下雨了。实际上在8月5日，对阵诺丁汉郡的比赛因为下雨而取消了。哦，哇。你看。所以雨席卷而来。
Yes. So bank holiday, lots of people go to the resorts. They're all excited. It's their big day out. If you went into London, there were crowds. Madame Tussauds, the famous waxworks, had a special exhibition, The Crisis of Europe, with a wax model of Franz Joseph, of King George, of the King of Serbia, and other sovereigns of Europe.
是的。所以银行假日，很多人去度假胜地。他们都很兴奋。这是他们的大日子。如果你走进伦敦，那里有很多人。杜莎夫人蜡像馆，著名的蜡像馆，有一个特别展览，《欧洲危机》，有弗朗茨·约瑟夫、乔治国王、塞尔维亚国王和欧洲其他君主的蜡像模型。
Do they have the Kaiser? I don't think they do, actually. I suppose you can understand why they wouldn't. He'd be a brilliant waxwork. Massive moustache. Well, I mean, he looks a bit like a waxwork as it is. Yeah. But I suppose they're worried of vandalism, maybe?
他们有凯撒吗？我想他们其实没有。我想你可以理解为什么他们不会有。他会是一个很棒的蜡像。巨大的胡子。好吧，我的意思是，他看起来本身就有点像蜡像。是的。但我猜他们担心破坏，也许？
When we went to Sarajevo, we saw a waxwork of- Franz Ferdinand. Archduke Franz Ferdinand and Sophie. They were terrible waxworks. They were. I don't mean to be rude to that very small and well-maintained museum in Sarajevo, which I recommend to all the listeners, but the waxworks... Could be improved upon.
当我们去萨拉热窝时，我们看到了一个蜡像——弗朗茨·斐迪南。弗朗茨·斐迪南大公和索菲。那是糟糕的蜡像。确实是。我不是想对萨拉热窝那个非常小且维护良好的博物馆无礼，我向所有听众推荐它，但蜡像……可以改进。
So while everybody is celebrating going to the beach and watching crickets, the news begins to rise in London that Belgium has rejected the German ultimatum, that there are huge crowds assembling in Belgian cities with Belgian flags. There's a story that the councillor at the German legation in Brussels looked out of his window at these crowds with Belgian flags and he said, the poor fools, why don't they get out of the way of the steamroller? We don't want to hurt them, but if they stand in our way, we will grind them into the dirt. Oh, the poor fools. But there's an irony there, isn't there? Because you could say the poor fools. I mean, who are the fools? Not the Belgians, but the Germans. Yeah, you could.
所以当每个人都在庆祝去海滩和看板球时，伦敦开始传出消息，比利时拒绝了德国的最后通牒，比利时城市里聚集了大量挥舞比利时国旗的群众。有一个故事说，德国驻布鲁塞尔公使馆的参赞从窗户看着这些挥舞比利时国旗的群众，他说，可怜的傻瓜，他们为什么不从压路机前走开？我们不想伤害他们，但如果他们挡在我们的路上，我们会把他们碾进泥土里。哦，可怜的傻瓜。但这里有一个讽刺，不是吗？因为你可以说可怜的傻瓜。我的意思是，谁是傻瓜？不是比利时人，而是德国人。是的，你可以。
Absolutely, you could. The cabinet in Britain met in 1115 that day and four of them, not particularly big hitters, four of them resign, but they resign on very good terms. So they basically say, listen, you guys want to have the war. That's fine. We can't be party to it because we're a more pacifist kind of inclination,
绝对可以。英国内阁那天11点15分会面，其中四个人，不是特别重要的人物，四个人辞职了，但他们是在非常好的条件下辞职的。所以他们基本上说，听着，你们想打仗。那很好。我们不能参与其中，因为我们更倾向于和平主义，
but we're not going to make a great fuss about it. We will support you from the back benches, but we just don't want to be parties to the decision. Gray tells his colleagues that Belgium has rejected the ultimatum. There's a lot of emotion in the room. There's probably a lot that seems to have been quite a lot of tears, but they are calm. They all accept that this is what's coming.
但我们不会为此大惊小怪。我们会在后座议员席上支持你们，但我们只是不想参与这个决定。格雷告诉他的同事们，比利时拒绝了最后通牒。房间里有很多情绪。可能有很多眼泪，但他们很冷静。他们都接受了这就是即将发生的事情。
And then Gray goes to the Commons, and he gives what some people, I think, could reasonably say one of the two or three greatest speeches in the Commons' history, a brilliant lawyer's brief, very powerful, perfectly calculated mixture of national interest and kind of moral authority. And he says to the MPs, you know, we don't have a recording of it because Parliament wasn't recorded, of course, in those days. He says, this is about British interests, British honour, and British obligations. He says, no one can deny we have this friendship with France. To every member to look into his own heart and his own feelings and to construe
然后格雷去了下议院，他发表了我认为有些人可以合理地说是下议院历史上两三次最伟大的演讲之一，一份出色的律师辩护词，非常有力量，完美计算了国家利益和某种道德权威的混合。他对议员们说，你知道，我们没有它的录音，因为当然，那个时代议会没有录音。他说，这是关于英国利益、英国荣誉和英国义务。他说，没有人能否认我们与法国有这种友谊。让每一位议员审视自己的内心和感受，并解释
the extent of that obligation for himself, as I had. I mean, true for members of parliament then and true for podcasters today, Dominic. Podcasters today. Yeah, I think everyone knows where I stand. He says the French coast is undefended and that's our fault. We told them to send their fleet away. He's not wrong about that. He's not wrong. He says we guarantee the independence of Belgium. We promised them that we would stand by them if they were ever attacked.
那种义务的程度，就像我一样。我的意思是，对当时的议员来说是真的，对今天的播客来说也是真的，多米尼克。今天的播客。是的，我想每个人都知道我的立场。他说法国海岸毫无防备，那是我们的错。我们告诉他们把舰队调走。他在这一点上没错。他没错。他说我们保证比利时的独立。我们向他们承诺，如果他们受到攻击，我们会支持他们。
Again, he's telling the truth. And he says, I want you to think what happens if France is beaten and we've stayed out? What happens if Belgium is defeated? What happens if... It's brilliant rhetoric, isn't it? Beaten to her knees, loses her position as a great power, becomes subordinate to the will and power of one greater than herself. Yeah. Kind of biblical quality to that.
同样，他在说实话。他说，我想让你们想想，如果法国被打败了，而我们袖手旁观会发生什么？如果比利时被击败了会发生什么？如果……这是精彩的修辞，不是吗？被打得跪下，失去了大国的地位，从属于一个比自己更强大的意志和力量。是的。有一种圣经般的品质。
Absolutely. But there's also, again, he doesn't say this is going to be a great laugh. He says, we are going to suffer, I'm afraid, terribly in this war, whether we're in it or whether we stand aside. But if we stand aside, we would sacrifice our respect and good name and reputation before the world, and we would not escape the most serious and grave economic consequences. Now, I think in that speech, I've just said what a brilliant speech it is, but I think what Gray does there is he invents the propagandistic British story of the First World War. So the longstanding friendship with France for generations, we've stood with the French. I mean, that's obviously rubbish.
绝对。但同样，他也没有说这会是一件很有趣的事。他说，恐怕无论我们参战还是袖手旁观，我们都会在这场战争中遭受惨重的损失。但如果我们袖手旁观，我们就会牺牲我们在世界面前的尊重、好名声和声誉，而且我们无法逃脱最严重和重大的经济后果。现在，我认为在那次演讲中，我刚刚说了那是一次多么精彩的演讲，但我认为格雷在那里所做的是他发明了第一次世界大战的宣传性英国故事。所以与法国几代人的长期友谊，我们一直与法国站在一起。我的意思是，那显然是胡说八道。
We've only had the Entente Cordiale for what, 10 years? I mean, France is our ancestral enemy, not our ancestral partner in arms. He doesn't talk about Austria and Serbia. He talks about Belgium. I mean, it's a brilliant piece of rhetoric. No one at this point is, I mean, everybody has forgotten Franz Ferdinand. It's all about Belgium. He's condensed the issue to Belgium. And of course, when you do that, then it becomes, seems much more clear cut. I always remember reading Barbara Tuchman's Guns of August, an incredibly popular book that JFK
我们只有《英法协约》才多少年？10年？我的意思是，法国是我们祖先的敌人，而不是我们祖先的战友。他没有谈论奥地利和塞尔维亚。他谈论的是比利时。我的意思是，这是一段精彩的修辞。此时没有人，我的意思是，每个人都忘记了弗朗茨·斐迪南。全是关于比利时。他把问题浓缩到了比利时。当然，当你这样做时，它就变得看起来清晰多了。我总是记得读芭芭拉·塔克曼的《八月的炮火》，一本非常受欢迎的书，肯尼迪
loved and everything. But I think in that, the assassination of Franz Ferdinand gets about two sentences. It's all about Belgium. Yeah. Isn't that interesting? I was reading some thread on Twitter a couple of days ago. There was actually an argument about the First World War, whether Britain should have stayed neutral. Nothing to do with this podcast or us. And I was reading all the replies. What? And the number of people who said, does Belgian independence mean nothing to you? You know, all of this kind of thing. Now, of course, there were people in the Foreign Office,
深受喜爱等等。但我认为在这些内容中，关于斐迪南大公遇刺的描述大概只有两句话。重点全在比利时。是啊，这难道不有趣吗？几天前我在推特上读到一个帖子。里面实际上有一场关于第一次世界大战的争论，讨论英国是否应该保持中立。这与本播客或我们无关。我读了所有的回复。什么？还有那么多人说，比利时的独立对你们来说毫无意义吗？你知道，诸如此类的话。当然，外交部里确实有人，
many of them the most vociferous advocates and most influential voices who were arguing for Britain to join the war long before the Belgian issue ever materialized. The Belgian issue was the most, I mean, I'm not saying it's nothing, of course not, but for somebody like Gray, the Belgian issue is not just important in and of itself, but it's the most wonderful vehicle to get people on board. And also the other idea that he sells quite
他们中的许多人是战争最激烈的鼓吹者和最有影响力的声音，早在比利时问题出现之前，他们就主张英国参战。比利时问题是最，我的意思是，我并不是说它毫无意义，当然不是，但对于像格雷这样的人来说，比利时问题不仅本身很重要，而且它是让人们支持参战的最绝妙的工具。还有他推销的另一个观点也相当
brilliantly is the idea that Germany has a long cherished plan to take over the continent and effectively the world, and that that is a deadly threat to Britain's empire. And that goes with the grain of British anxiety about the naval race. Exactly. The naval race and the economic competition. So there are lots of people who are absolutely, you know, who already believe that actually, Tom. However, all that said, what he says about the French fleet and the risk to the...
出色，那就是德国有一个长期酝酿的计划，旨在接管欧洲大陆，实际上是接管整个世界，这对大英帝国构成了致命威胁。这与英国对海军竞赛的焦虑不谋而合。没错。海军竞赛和经济竞争。所以有很多人绝对，你知道，他们本来就相信这一点，汤姆。然而，话虽如此，他关于法国舰队以及对……的风险所说的话，
I mean, that does seem to me... I mean, you can't argue that. Well, we'll wait for the bonus episode to see whether I can argue it, Tom. So that afternoon, Germany formally declares war on France. Yet again, more tears. The German ambassador,
我的意思是，这在我看来确实……我的意思是，你无法反驳这一点。好吧，我们等加更集来看看我是否能反驳它，汤姆。那天下午，德国正式对法国宣战。又是更多的泪水。德国大使，
Wilhelm von Schoen, goes to the Quai d'Orsay in Paris. There's a big crowd. He's actually jostled and he has to be escorted by police to get in. He goes in to see poor old René Viviani, who's already a broken man himself.
威廉·冯·舍恩，前往巴黎的奥赛码头。那里聚集了一大群人。他实际上被推搡着，不得不由警察护送才能进入。他进去见可怜的老勒内·维维亚尼，他自己也已经是一个心力交瘁的人了。
Schoen gives Viviani his card on the way out, and on the back he's written, C'est le suicide de l'Europe. It's the suicide of Europe. So he's devastated as well. Viviani is sort of trembling and stuff. The only person who's really delighted is President Poincaré, the man of Lorraine.
舍恩在离开时给了维维亚尼一张名片，背面写着：C'est le suicide de l'Europe（这是欧洲的自杀）。所以他也崩溃了。维维亚尼当时浑身颤抖之类的。唯一真正感到高兴的是普恩加莱总统，那个洛林人。
Yeah. He's got the war he deep down probably always wanted. Britain still hasn't entered. It's that night, actually. It's before Britain has entered the war. Grey is standing at his window looking out over Birdcage Wall. Is dusk falling, Dominic? Dusk is falling.
是的。他得到了他内心深处可能一直想要的战争。英国还没有加入。实际上就在那天晚上。是在英国参战之前。格雷站在窗前，望着鸟笼步道。多米尼克，黄昏降临了吗？黄昏正在降临。
Dusk is falling and are the lamplighters going up and down the streets yeah the lamplighters are out and is he about to make one of the most famous lines in the whole of 20th century history tom you're so dismissive i can't believe you're this is usually my job on the podcast it's such a famous line because it's so haunting yeah i mean it kind of sums up the entire mood of this podcast. And I haven't even revealed what it is. So Dominic, give us Sir Edward Gray's classic line. The lamps are going out all over Europe. We shall not see them lit again in our lifetime. I mean, that is very powerful. That's brilliant, isn't it? So here's the question. Did he really say that? I think he did. He said it to a guy called J.A. Spender, who recorded it, who was the editor of the Westminster Gazette,
黄昏正在降临，点灯人正在街上走来走去吗？是的，点灯人出动了。他是否即将说出20世纪历史上最著名的台词之一？汤姆，你太轻视了，我真不敢相信，这通常是我的工作。这句台词之所以如此出名，是因为它太令人难忘了。是的，我的意思是，它总结了本播客的整体基调。而且我甚至还没透露它是什么。所以多米尼克，给我们念一下爱德华·格雷爵士的经典台词吧。欧洲各地的灯火正在熄灭。我们有生之年恐怕再也看不到它们重新点亮了。我的意思是，这非常有力量。这太精彩了，不是吗？所以问题来了。他真的说了吗？我想他说了。他是对一个叫J.A.斯彭德的人说的，此人记录了下来，他是《威斯敏斯特公报》的编辑，
who was with him at the time. Spender wrote about it in his memoir, and then it became enshrined in historiography. I mean, it's such a perfect line, and it's so resonant and famous that I'm a slight element of suspicion about it. But Gray is a melancholy man and a very clever man, and he's looking out of the window, and there's no reason to believe they're not lighting their lamps.
当时他就在他身边。斯彭德在回忆录中写到了这件事，然后它就被载入了史学。我的意思是，这是一句如此完美的台词，如此响亮且著名，以至于我对此有一点怀疑。但格雷是一个忧郁且非常聪明的人，他正望着窗外，没有理由相信他们没有在点灯。
All right. Well, I'm glad to know that he really said it. The next day, Tuesday, everyone, of course, has gone back to work because the bank holiday is over. The German army crossed the Belgian border just after 8 o'clock. There is now an amazingly, if anybody thinks I've been too Teutonophile in this series, one of the most stirring scenes of the whole saga is King Albert of Belgium.
好吧。很高兴知道他确实说了。第二天，星期二，每个人当然都回去工作了，因为银行假日结束了。德国军队在8点刚过就越过了比利时边境。现在有一个令人惊叹的场景，如果有人认为我在这个系列中太亲德了，那么整个传奇中最激动人心的场景之一就是比利时的阿尔贝国王。
At noon, he sends a formal appeal to Britain for help as the guarantor of Belgium's independence. Then he's in his uniform. He gets on a charger, a horse. He rides through the streets of Brussels at the head of a procession of carriages, one of which holds his wife and children. And he rides all the way to the Belgian parliament and he goes into the chamber in his uniform and he says in French to the assembled deputies or whatever they are,
中午，他作为比利时独立的担保人，正式向英国发出求援呼吁。然后他穿上军装。他骑上一匹战马。他骑马穿过布鲁塞尔的街道，带领着一列马车队伍，其中一辆载着他的妻子和孩子。他一直骑到比利时议会，穿着军装走进议会大厅，并用法语对聚集的代表们说道，
gentlemen, are you determined at any cost to preserve the sacred heritage of our forefathers? And as a man, they get to their feet and they're shouting, oui, oui, oui. You know, it's proper stirring stuff. And brilliant for Paul Campbell, who doesn't need to have it translated. Yes.
先生们，你们是否决心不惜一切代价保卫我们祖先的神圣遗产？所有人齐刷刷地站了起来，高喊着：Oui, oui, oui（是的，是的，是的）。你知道，这真是令人振奋。这对保罗·坎贝尔来说太棒了，他不需要翻译就能听懂。是的。
He would approve of that. He would. Being a Frenchman, he would probably say something disobliging about the Belgian accent. He'd sneer at the accent. Yes, he would. He would.
他会赞同这一点。他会的。作为一个法国人，他可能会对比利时的口音说些刻薄的话。他会嘲笑那种口音。是的，他会。他会的。
So that morning, the cabinet met again in London to sign off an ultimatum to Germany, telling them to withdraw from Belgium. Gray met the American ambassadors, the first mention of the Americans in this whole story, that afternoon. And Gray said to him, thus the efforts of a lifetime go for nothing. I feel like a man who has wasted his life. And Margot Asquith, she went to see the German ambassador again, Lichnowsky, and Lichnowsky said to her, you knew we must go through Belgium,
那天早上，内阁在伦敦再次开会，签署了给德国的最后通牒，要求他们撤出比利时。格雷那天下午会见了美国大使，这是整个故事中第一次提到美国人。格雷对他说，我一生的努力就这样付诸东流了。我觉得自己是一个虚度了一生的人。玛戈·阿斯奎斯，她再次去见了德国大使利希诺夫斯基，利希诺夫斯基对她说，你知道我们必须穿过比利时，
there is no other way. We never counted on that old, old treaty. Oh dear, oh dear, don't go to war. I felt too sad to speak, wrote Margot. We sat and cried on the green sofa. I mean, you know, it is quite, it is moving stuff. And they then,
没有别的办法。我们从未指望那个古老的条约。噢天哪，噢天哪，不要开战。我难过得说不出话来，玛戈写道。我们坐在绿色沙发上哭泣。我的意思是，你知道，这确实很感人。然后他们，
after Britain's declaration of war, the Lichnowskys go to Harwich. And at Harwich, they find that a guard of honour has been drawn up for them. Really? So they walk through this guard of honour. Livnovsky writes about it in his memoirs. I was treated like a departing sovereign. Such was the end of my London mission.
在英国宣战后，利希诺夫斯基夫妇前往哈里奇。在哈里奇，他们发现那里为他们准备了一支仪仗队。真的吗？所以他们走过了这支仪仗队。利希诺夫斯基在回忆录中写道：我受到了像一位即将离任的君主般的礼遇。这就是我伦敦使命的终结。
Oh, it's kind of sad, all this, isn't it, Tom? It's very sad. In Berlin, the Kaiser has now got used to his new part, and he's loving it, actually. He receives every deputy at the Reichstag at his palace. He's in his helmet. He's in his uniform. He has his new title.
噢，这一切都有点悲伤，不是吗，汤姆？非常悲伤。在柏林，德皇现在已经习惯了他的新角色，实际上他很喜欢。他在宫殿里接见每一位国会议员。他戴着头盔。他穿着军装。他有了新的头衔。
He is now the Supreme Warlord, which I assume he loves. Yeah, of course he loves that. The little boy in him absolutely loves being the Supreme Warlord. And he says. Yeah, of course he loves that. The little boy in him absolutely loves being the Supreme Warlord. And he says to them, we draw the sword with a clear conscience and with clean hands. And every great power is saying that. Isn't that amazing? And believing it. Yeah.
他现在是最高统帅，我想他一定很喜欢。是的，他当然喜欢。他内心深处的小男孩绝对喜欢当最高统帅。他对他们说，我们怀着清白的良心和干净的双手拔剑。每个大国都在这么说。这难道不令人惊奇吗？而且深信不疑。是的。
They're all saying this. Of course, everybody at the beginning of any war thinks that they are in the right. But that sense of being embattled, encircled. Well, the contrast is surely with the Second World War. Yeah. I mean, in the Second World War, the Germans launch invasions that are absolutely acts of aggression and they're proud about it.
他们都在这么说。当然，任何战争开始时，每个人都认为自己是正义的。但那种被围困、被包围的感觉。嗯，这肯定与第二次世界大战形成了对比。是的。我的意思是，在第二次世界大战中，德国人发动的入侵绝对是侵略行为，他们对此感到自豪。
Yeah, you're absolutely right. But in this, that's not happening. Well, first of all, in the Second World War, you don't have people bursting into tears all the time. No. And guards of honour for them or people lending them money to get home and all of that kind of stuff.
是的，你说得完全对。但在这次战争中，情况并非如此。嗯，首先，在第二次世界大战中，你不会看到人们一直泪流满面。不。也不会有为他们准备的仪仗队，或者人们借钱给他们回家之类的各种事情。
Yeah, get their wife back from holiday. Exactly. We did a series, I think we mentioned this earlier, it's worth reiterating. We did a series about the rise of the Nazis. And you don't understand where the Nazis come from if you don't understand that basically everybody in Germany, with the exception of Prince Lefkoski, thinks they are blameless. They did the right thing and they've been betrayed and stabbed in the back and that they're fighting a defensive war.
是的，把他们的妻子从度假中接回来。没错。我们做过一个系列，我想我们之前提到过，值得重申。我们做过一个关于纳粹崛起的系列。如果你不明白基本上德国的每个人，除了利希诺夫斯基亲王之外，都认为自己是无辜的，认为他们做了正确的事，却被背叛、被背后捅刀子，并且他们是在进行一场防御性战争，你就无法理解纳粹是从哪里来的。
Bethman Holveg addresses the Reichstag deputies, the chancellor, and he says, we are fighting for our lives. Yes, we are breaking the law by going through Belgium and Luxembourg, and we know it is wrong, but we will make it good as soon as we are safe. When you are as imperiled as we are, fighting for everything we hold dear, you can only think of how you will cut your way out. I mean, that's how they justify it to themselves
贝特曼·霍尔维格向国会议员发表讲话，这位总理说，我们正在为生存而战。是的，我们通过比利时和卢森堡违反了法律，我们知道这是错误的，但一旦我们安全了，我们会弥补的。当你像我们一样处于危险之中，为我们所珍视的一切而战时，你只能考虑如何杀出一条血路。我的意思是，这就是他们如何向自己证明这一点。
because some of this is maybe thinking, how do the Germans justify it? And they effectively say, we have been forced. We have no option because the other option is death. And this is the tone that he adopts when he meets with the british ambassador yes after this yes and of course the british ambassador is bringing the declaration of war yeah we're fighting for our life against two assailants you joining the war britain is like striking a man from behind it's very much it's so interesting
因为有些人可能在想，德国人是如何证明这一点的？他们实际上说，我们是被迫的。我们别无选择，因为另一个选择就是死亡。这就是他会见英国大使时采取的基调，是的，在这次之后，是的，当然英国大使带来了宣战书，是的，我们正在为生存而战，对抗两个袭击者。你们加入战争，英国就像是在背后袭击一个人。这太有趣了，
how they all use analogies and and sort of idioms drawn from sport or school stories. You never hit a man when he's down. That's what they're saying. But also that, I mean, it's kind of only a piece of paper. So the British ambassador says, we're all on a bound to defend Belgium. And Bethlehem says, but what at what price? You were fighting just for a word, neutrality, just for a scrap of paper. Great Britain is going to make war on a kindred nation who want nothing better than to be friends with her. Yeah. And that phrase, the scrap of paper,
他们都使用从体育或校园故事中汲取的类比和习语。你永远不会在一个人倒下时打他。这就是他们所说的。但这也意味着，我的意思是，这只是一张纸。所以英国大使说，我们都有义务保卫比利时。贝特曼说，但代价是什么？你们只是为了一个词，中立，只是为了废纸一张而战。大英国竟然要向一个只想与她友好的同族国家开战。是的。而那句“废纸一张”，
if you go to the Imperial War Museum in London, they have loads of propaganda posters. That phrase, the scrap of paper, was a gift to Britain because our propagandists used it understandably. They would do a poster of the treaty and they would say, the Germans think this is just a scrap of paper, but this is the guarantee of Belgium's freedom. This is what we're fighting for. This is what it's all about. This is what it's all about. Exactly. And at the end of that interview, so it's Bethman Holweg and the British ambassador,
如果你去伦敦的帝国战争博物馆，他们有很多宣传海报。“废纸一张”这句话对英国来说是一份礼物，因为我们的宣传人员理所当然地利用了它。他们会制作一张条约的海报，然后说，德国人认为这只是一张废纸，但这却是比利时自由的保障。这就是我们为之奋斗的目标。这就是一切的意义所在。这就是一切的意义所在。没错。在那次采访结束时，也就是贝特曼·霍尔维格和英国大使之间，
who's called Sir Edward Goshen. Do they cry? They're both in tears. Goshen actually says to Bethman Holweg, please, can I go into your antechamber? I need to compose myself before I walk out. I don't want all your staff to see me crying i mean and beth manholveg says of course you can as a gentleman and all that kind of stuff and that's what happens quite disappointed the british ambassador burst into tears
那位大使叫爱德华·戈申爵士。他们哭了吗？他们都泪流满面。戈申实际上对贝特曼·霍尔维格说，请问，我能去你的前厅吗？我需要在走出去之前平复一下心情。我不想让你的所有员工看到我哭。我的意思是，贝特曼·霍尔维格说，当然可以，作为绅士等等。事情就是这样发生的，英国大使非常失望地泪流满面。
no i think it reflects poor i think it reflects well on him tom no excitable continentals bursting into tears is one thing but a brit British ambassador bursting into tears, very poor. Well, you'll approve of what happens next then, because that night, it's actually, the funny thing about the story is it was very unclear. The British worded their ultimatum poorly, so it wasn't clear whether it would expire at 11 o'clock or 12 o'clock British time,
不，我认为这反映了，我认为这对他评价很好，汤姆。不，情绪激动的欧洲人泪流满面是一回事，但英国大使泪流满面，非常糟糕。好吧，那你一定会赞同接下来发生的事情，因为那天晚上，实际上，这个故事有趣的地方在于它非常不明确。英国人把他们的最后通牒措辞写得很糟糕，所以不清楚它是在英国时间11点还是12点到期，
because of the time difference. So anyway, that evening, as darkness draws in, Sir Edward Grey goes to Downing Street and he sits in the cabinet room with Asquith, with Winston Churchill, with their friend Richard Haldane, with David Lloyd George. And they're just waiting for news from Berlin to see if a reply comes to the ultimatum, whether they're going to get out of Belgium. And no news comes. And the reason is the telegraph lines have already been cut because of course there's
因为时差的原因。总之，那天晚上，随着夜幕降临，爱德华·格雷爵士前往唐宁街，他与阿斯奎斯、温斯顿·丘吉尔、他们的朋友理查德·霍尔丹、大卫·劳合·乔治坐在内阁会议室里。他们只是在等待柏林的消息，看看对最后通牒是否有回复，看看他们是否会撤出比利时。但没有消息传来。原因是因为电报线路已经被切断了，因为当然，
no way the germans are going to change their mind now and at 11 o'clock big ben strikes and they hear through the windows the sound of a great crowd that's assembled outside the palace of westminster singing god save the king you know greeting the arrival of the declaration of war and it's just a few minutes after that that a signal flashes from the admiralty to britain's fleet across the world and the signal reads simply commence hostilities at once against germany so there we are the world is at war and we will continue the story won't we uh in due course, probably next year when we look at the guns of August and maybe right the way up to the Battle of the Marne and maybe even the Christmas truce. But for now, we're not going to completely finish discussing this because next week's bonus episode for subscribers to the Restless History Club, we'll be looking at some of the broader issues that surround this, some of the various perspectives that different historians have taken, some of
德国人现在不可能改变主意了。11点钟，大本钟敲响了，他们通过窗户听到了议会大厦外聚集的一大群人高唱《天佑国王》的声音，你知道，迎接宣战的到来。就在那几分钟后，海军部向世界各地的英国舰队发出信号，信号内容很简单：立即对德国采取敌对行动。所以就这样，世界陷入了战争。我们将继续讲述这个故事，不是吗？嗯，在适当的时候，可能明年，当我们回顾八月的炮火，甚至可能一直讲到马恩河战役，甚至可能是圣诞休战。但现在，我们不会完全结束讨论，因为下周给订阅者的加更集，我们将探讨围绕此事的更广泛的问题，探讨不同历史学家所采取的各种观点，探讨一些
the big talking points, the big debates, and we will be responding to comments, criticisms, points of view that perhaps you might want to put to us either on the Discord if you're a club member or on Twitter or X or whatever it is. Or you can email us at the Rest Is History website. So that will be for subscribers. And if you're not a subscriber or on twitter or x or whatever it is or you can email us at the rest is history website so that will be for subscribers and if you're not a subscriber already you just need to go to the rest of history.com to sign up you know the form you've heard this a multitude of times and that is the end of one of the great titanic episodes of european history and on monday we will be starting a new series on another of the great Titanic episodes, perhaps one of the most Titanic episode of all, and that's the French Revolution. And we will be beginning that by looking at yet more Habsburg shenanigans,
重大的谈话要点、重大的辩论，我们将回应评论、批评、观点，也许你们想在Discord（如果你是俱乐部成员）或推特或X或其他平台上向我们提出。或者你可以通过“Rest Is History”网站给我们发电子邮件。所以这些内容将提供给订阅者。如果你还不是订阅者，或者在推特或X或其他平台上，或者你可以通过“Rest Is History”网站给我们发电子邮件，所以这些内容将提供给订阅者。如果你还不是订阅者，你只需要去therestishistory.com注册，你知道那个表格，你已经听过无数次了。这就是欧洲历史上最伟大的泰坦尼克式剧集之一的终结。周一，我们将开始一个新的系列，讲述另一个伟大的泰坦尼克式剧集，也许是所有剧集中最泰坦尼克式的一部，那就是法国大革命。我们将从回顾更多的哈布斯堡家族闹剧开始，
because we will be looking at Marie Antoinette. So thank you very much for listening. Thank you, Dominic, for absolutely brilliant narrative tour de force. And thank you, everyone who has listened to it. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes,
因为我们将回顾玛丽·安托瓦内特。非常感谢大家的收听。谢谢你，多米尼克，带来了一场绝对精彩的叙事杰作。也谢谢所有收听的人。再见。再见。《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的地方，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更集，
and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及提前获得现场演出门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。网址是therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。